[Musique]
bonjour à tous mesdames et messieurs
désolé pour ce petit retard il y a eu un
petit bug
à l'allumage mais on a on a rien
ratéphane donc ça c'est quand même la
Bonne Nouvelle oui oui
c'est parti mais ça va on va être bien à
l'heure pour regarder donc ce fabuleux
match entre Fabiano gueruana et Levan à
rognan alors attendant je crois pas que
ce soit un autre but de match entre
Fabienne ocarwana et alors
encore mieux en fait d'ailleurs et après
eux ils gagnent ils rejurons parce que
demain en fait ce sont les deux parties
des des perdants donc là ils avancent
petit à petit
dans le dans le classement Fab
mais ouais ça va être une journée assez
assez extraordinaire on va on va suivre
un match de loser bracket et le match
Abdou ça t'auras Carlsen donc on va voir
un spectacle fabuleux aujourd'hui oui
la finale des
Winners à partir de ce soir on aura plus
qu'un seul genre à ne pas avoir perdu
déjà incroyable mais tous les autres
encore en cours avec donc là deux grands
matchs dans cette demi-finale mon quart
de finale peut-être on va dire 12 heures
donc il y a Wesley Sow qui affronte
Fabiano caroana un peu la surprise de ce
tournoi contre Levon à rognan
Maxime va chez Lagrave donc quand même
ex champion du monde j'étais inquiet de
voir que cet événement de prestige
n'était pas encore retransmis donc il y
a quand même une énorme attente avec
avec ces matchs et des Fabien sont
surprises le le tableau des perdants oui
qui déjà beaucoup d'enjeux
assez assez exceptionnel donc là c'est
vrai que nous on était on était très
très mal j'ai appelé l'assistance
technique etc il y avait des problèmes
de serveur j'étais très très inquiet que
l'on rate cet événement majeur de de la
saison Fabien je crois qu'ils ont envoyé
Dany branché les câbles ouais ça aurait
été vraiment
problématique
mais là ça va on est bien on peut se
détendre bon d'ailleurs
ça tombe bien ouf par chance aujourd'hui
vraiment une exceptionnellement non pas
commencé à l'heure
17h pétantes là bon
dans le bon tempo
à moins que les deux autres jouent ouais
non je sais pas je peux pas je peux pas
te dire non non j'ai l'impression qu'ils
sont en retard et ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle de la journée
ça permet aussi que ça finisse un petit
peu plus tard pour les retards de la
terre voilà profiter de la soirée où il
fait un peu plus frais pour bien suivre
ce stream et ce tournoi surtout vérifie
que de tension
les joueurs doivent être très très
stressé c'est un événement quand même un
des tournois majeurs de leur saison un
peu bizarre que la Coupe du Monde de
l'UE après j'aurais pensé avec nous on
doit servir de tremplin d'échauffement
en fait un peu pour arriver lancée Coupe
du monde en plus jouer avec des matchs à
élimination direct tu vois ça t'aurait
habitué un petit peu à ça alors que là
si tu perds tu es tout de suite illuminé
c'est vrai que ça change c'est vrai que
ça change alors que là alors que là tu
as quand même cette deuxième vie cette
deuxième chance mais c'est vrai que dans
un tournoi assis important ce serait
dommage de pas être sûr que les
meilleurs gagne et cette deuxième vie
permet vraiment que les gros poissons ne
puissent pas sortir sur un un jour j'ai
envie de dire de deux malchance un jour
un petit peu à côté complètement alors
moi on est complètement sûr qui qui soit
soit bien là jusqu'au bout alors sauf
méga m'effort qui peut arriver
mais normalement
on doit avoir du Carlson en finale on
l'espère en tout cas
la finale c'est souvent quand même les
deux qui vont en finale du Winner qui se
retrouvent en finale après une deuxième
fois les plus forts
mais tu as la sécurité quand même
d'avoir
une surprise d'être bien sûr de pas en
avoir ou que j'ai eu un mauvais tableau
peut-être avec une sorte de
Icare ou Carlson au premier tour tu
seras un peu dégoûté tu dis non mais ça
c'est une finale faut pas que c'est lui
là donc tu trouves un moyen pour quand
même l'avoir en finale c'est sympa et
Maxime je trouve cela dur l'appellation
loser bracket peut-être aussi de
l'appeler le potential winner bracket
pour être en good vibes c'est vrai et
encore des des améliorations c'est vrai
Maxime
à avoir je crois que ça va très bien tôt
commencer Fabien je sais que tu es
impatient
tu vas en parler ce matin
tu étais déjà en train de de languir
de ces matchs
donc peut-être plus de cela que du
Carlson personnellement oui parce que le
perdant pourra encore revenir voilà
alors que là c'est vrai que c'est encore
c'est vrai que tu as tu as raison Fabien
historique ce matin tu étais un peu
stressé hein l'idée de d'imaginer
Fabiano caroana ou Levana Ronan éliminé
voilà voilà vraiment dans la compétition
de genre qui je pense mériteraient de
continuer parcours qui ont quand même
passé le premier tour
et donc qui mérite quand même de
d'avancer dans ce dans ce tournoi mais
il y en aura qu'un qui gagnera
malheureusement
ce tournoi avec Fabian on peut le
montrer en attendant qu'il remportera
magnifique
vous pouvez voir le trophée du tournoi
avec une coupe un cerveau le winner
dessus
chaise chambres le petit avion qui
t'écrit à me chasse rapide
on fait
qualitatif on aimerait bien avoir à la
maison mais nous Fabien on ne pourra pas
l'emporter ce trophée non
malheureusement
c'est aussi vu la vidéo sur Twitter avec
le la partie entre OL et Carlsen qui
joue avec les boîtiers R6 boîtier blanc
contre boîtier noir mais bravo de
reconnaître des pièces
une prouesse j'ai envie de dire
dans le chat derrière la qualité de
l'air comme un grand maître 35% de
réduction sur
ringways
il a peut-être bien pot d'échappement
dans sa chambre je sais pas ce qu'il a
fait hyper humide c'est n'importe quoi
là du coup je vais donner Wesley gros
favorite ce match vu les infos que j'ai
là
ça paraît ça paraît compliqué mais
comment comment arriver à bien jouer
dans telle condition ce sera vraiment un
exploit incroyable on va voir on va
suivre Fabi mais les gaffes devraient
pleuvoir dans cette partie je pense à
mon avis aussi Fabien
à mon avis aussi
j'ai du mal à l'imaginer l'emporter
commence pas on est en train de se
le niveau de stress est en train de
monter à l'attention de me monter d'un
cran dans le studio Fabien non mais
complètement
mais d'ailleurs je ne vois pas où est
connecté
c'est plus grosse prépa ici si vous êtes
un théoricien de premier plan prenez des
notes oui ça peut sortir de la nouveauté
théorique
c'est quand même connecté E4 5 et une
petite italienne c'est parti
enfin moi je vais aller un tout petit
peu récupérer
[Musique]
je vais je vais le faire alors je me
hop je me repositionne
H3 jouets contrôle cette case G4 qui est
évité éventuellement qu'un cavalier
Vienne dessus faire pression sur F2 si
la tourner à partir
et également de pouvoir jouer des cartes
plus facilement puisque on aura plus
besoin de
se casser la tête s'il y avait un
clouage
donc H3 jouets dessus bon les normes
bien sûr en plein d'options il a choisi
à 5
tours 1 jouer maintenant
il faut aussi se propose l'échange des
fous alors bon on a déjà vu un peu ça
hier on sait qu'en cas de prise les
Noirs prennent du pion et ça renforce
leur centre donc très souvent les blancs
refusent cet échange soit en se
zigzagant avec le fou bah voilà c'est ce
qui vient de faire quitte à repartir
là-bas verset 2 soit en gardant le
vis-à-vis donc B5 a été le coup choisi
par Fabiano fois 7 jouets par Wesley
alors important quand même à noter que
s'il a une énorme ne font rien attention
les blancs pourraient faire des quatre
attaque ce fou une fois qu'il s'en va il
y a des cinq fourchette donc x 7 ça
évite ce genre de mésaventures
ça serait quand même dommage de perdre
si rapidement la partie
mais Wesley est bien au courant de tout
ça et ça va avec le fou
du coup Fabiano
ici au très bas Peugeot différents
pour retourner de ce côté là bas à noter
aussi comme le cahier la caisse C6
maintenant peut-être le pion pour
avancer chasser fou et préparer le
taremment une poussée des cinq
donc c'est à Wesley noir et d'ailleurs
il réfléchit doit hésiter sûrement entre
C6 ou cavaliers G6 deux coups fort
naturel il a choisi cavalier G6
et Wesley pour pendant Fabiano pour en
faire de même et je vois qu'il y a les
G3 à son tour ou peut-être d'ores et
déjà le coup des quatre qui placerait
spion au centre et ce qu'on aimerait
bien faire dans un position et je vous
dis d'abord que les G3 un coup de
placement qui remet de cavalier sur une
position naturelle qui aide à bien
défendre ce pion et peut-être par la
suite venir faire un tour sur la case F5
donc on va voir si Wesley prend
l'initiative de cette poussée centrale
avec C6 D5 en premier ou s'il laisse
faire Fabiano avec des 4
en tout cas d'opposition relativement
symétrique c'est si je joue attaque le
fou qui recule il va en A4
et donc dessus voilà peut-être peut-être
des cinq peut-être y avoir le préparer
dans un coup comme H6
au préalable mais il a choisi donc des 5
d'ores et déjà
d'ores et déjà le coup des cinq alors
souvent les blancs aiment bien prendre
en se disant voilà j'ai mis la tour ici
pour attaquer le pion E5 et
donc les Noirs pourraient reprendre soit
de la dame pour le défendre mais ça
laisserait peut-être un coup de fou B3
on peut aussi prendre du cavalier parce
que le truc c'est que maintenant si les
blancs prennent le pion ils vont se
prendre une une double attaque puisque
la tour est pas défendue il y a quand
même sur le fou qui regarde vers F2 et
donc ce genre de coupe peut être très
pénible puisque sur reprend quand même
le coup qu'on a envie de faire il y a
d'un f-6 et je sais qui attaque la tour
donc
ce petit coup permet de tenir de manière
tactique le pion le pion de 5 qui n'est
pas vraiment en l'air à vrai dire du
coup il y a eu prise il a donc repris du
cavalier il y a eu des quatre deux
jouets donc ne tombe pas dans le piège
un piège bien connu et il fait des 4
prises prises et la position on devient
assez symétrique en termes de structure
de pions mais le Fou est attaqué par le
cavalier il a pas de super case de repli
après il faut quand même noter que si on
prend ce fou les Nord prennent du pion
ça emmène ma structure mais ça ouvre la
Tour Eiffel en F2 en compagnie du Fou
donc ça pourrait donner peut-être un
certain dynamisme noir dans la position
donc peut-être qu'ils ne sont pas
obligés de de reculer ce fou aussi
et pourrait jouer différemment avoir
après il peut aussi songer à des coups
peut-être de cavalier F4 vers l'avant un
petit dames C7 qui permet de lier les
tours qui pourraient nervir le centre
tout en regardant ce cavalier là-bas qui
n'est pas complètement défendu par spion
avec les histoires de cloises donc
sûrement plusieurs options et à noter
que probablement fouder 7 peut-être est
jouable mais avoir sur une si bonne idée
de perdre du temps comme ça dès
maintenant parce que sous des apparences
calme la position peut s’animer
rapidement la dame peut participer à
l'attaque les cavaliers peuvent venir
l'un ou l'autre par ici donc ça peut
aller assez vite en fait c'est position
alors on va voir ça ouest jouer il a le
temps de toute façon c'était parti
rapide mais cela dit bien assez longue
puisqu'ils ont 15 minutes + 3 secondes
par coup c'est souvent des parties qui
durent bien plus d'une demi-heure et il
a donc bien raison de prendre son temps
pour pour choisir la meilleure
solution possible dans dans cette
position
toute la famille assez vite ouverture il
a toujours 13 minutes 30 à la pendule
donc il a fait moins de enfin pas moins
il a fait une minute trente de réflexion
plus les petits rajouts bon qui connaît
bien ce genre de position de toute façon
ces étalé dans les voies jouées hyper
souvent au niveau maintenant c'est
devenu tout aussi important et principal
que les Espagnols alors j'ai choisi dame
6 7
donc qui place la dame pour regarder ce
cavalier et donc en cas de prise en
E6 je sais pas si compte faire dame
prend G3 ou f prend le 6 ou peut-être
encore autre chose possible
mais en tout cas dans tous les noirs ça
a l'air ça a l'air intéressant de
prendre ce cavalier ici ça attaque F2
les blancs sûrement doivent jouer
cavaliers ici pour
la diagonale de fou la dame se retrouve
attaquée elle veut venir ici et ça reste
peut-être menaçant côté noir qui peuvent
débarquer
pas obligé de faire de me prendre j'ai
trois peut-être puis on prend et
d'ailleurs puisqu'on attaque à la fois
ce pion et ce cavalier
c'est peut-être une bonne option et
peut-être même que ce coût serait
jouable attire le roi prend en faisant
échec le roi s'en va et à ce moment
prendra donc tout ça pour dire qu'a
priori dame c'est 7 ça part totalement
qui allait prendre aussi
il faut juste dire autre chose que tu es
blanc d'ailleurs Fabiano a choisi autre
chose il a fait pousser deux il a fait
pousser deux il est parti de cette
diagonale ou fou ne faisait plus grand
chose dans A4 pour revenir sur cette
diagonale plus menaçante
donc je sais pas si on menace encore
quel pronostic il y a toujours peut-être
la même histoire mais peut-être la dame
pourrait aller vers H5 être conservé
avec son fou peut-être avec les
cavaliers peut-être des fois je suis des
cahiers prangers certains jours vont
arriver on va voir
pousser de jouer et donc position tendue
tout peut se passer
les pièces sont plutôt bien placées de
part et d'autre et que cette tour qui
participe pas trop au jeu côté blanc
mais on n'a pas encore trop trop besoin
donc avoir un vrai que Fabiano malgré
son air catastrophique
qui a été de l'air très pauvre comme
l'indique son boîtier pour l'instant il
ne chute pas il trouve des bons coups il
n'a pas fait de calibre aussi ni le
calibre 5 au mauvais moment donc il
évite pour l'instant les pièges adverse
tout à 8 joué par Wesley donc il ramène
sa tour en jeu sur une colonne ouverte
c'est très bien
et on va voir
comment Fabiano réagit maintenant
mais j'ai l'impression que l'ouverture
est plutôt une réussite côté Wesley en
fait même si la position a très
compliqué de partir d'autres
j'ai pas l'impression que les noirs et
particulièrement de problèmes dans cette
position ils ont plutôt bien mis leur
pièce en place
et ça doit aller
donc peut-être à Fabiano de résoudre je
sais pas s'il a des problèmes réellement
mais
bon c'est jamais marrant avec les Blancs
après 15 coups de se retrouver comme ça
et
d'être légèrement sous pression il fait
fout des deux
petit coup de développement c'est pas
mal sur un site tour donc de participer
au jeu ça défend un peu plus cette tour
là
peut-être un coup comme c'est 8 très
possible cache le fou évite de réfléchir
plus au cas il prend aussi mais si il y
a sûrement encore il faut prendre
marcher dessus
mais bon il serait pas implacer là-bas
ou peut-être un coup un coup plus vers
l'avant un coup de cavalier vers ici
on va voir
en tout cas les joueurs très motivés en
terme de ce match qui arrive à jouer
assez vite de très bons coups
mais petit avantage avantage pardon à la
pendule pour pour Fabiano
s'il y a ouais plus de 2 minutes
d'avance sur sur Westland
ah ça change quoi la qualité de l'air et
pourquoi est-elle mesurée ah bah ça
change
ça change la capacité à jouer des bons
coups a priori voilà c'est la
technologie ring qui permet donc de
savoir la qualité de l'air chez toi
et plus tu as un air pur plus peut-être
ton cerveau est à l'affût et oxygénée et
te permettre d'être
concentré sur ta partie être attentif
être voilà être en pleine forme pour
pour trouver les meilleurs coups c'est
un jeu de précision donc aucun détail ne
doit être négligé
en tout cas Fabiano malgré ce boîtier il
doit avoir les indications il n'a pas
fait les réglages adéquats
engager une équipe de
chez lui pour purifier l'air enlever un
peu ce CO2 rafraîchir un peu ces 27
degrés là qui sont quand même très chaud
et donc voilà alors cavalid DF4 jouer
[Musique]
chez Wesley donc oui beaucoup normal qui
replace ce cavalier un peu de manière
agressive vers vers le roi adverse qui
libère éventuellement la case des 5 pour
mettre le fou
ça pourrait être utile peut-être à un
moment
et
voilà donc pas trop de pas trop de
problèmes alors est-ce que ce coup est
possible
[Musique]
je sais pas en tout cas il y a plus les
deux qui marche ça déjà c'est la bonne
nouvelle côté blanc
bon déjà on peut reprendre bêtement et
peut-être il y a décalé prend H3 et sur
pions prendre à me prendre mais bon quel
est proche je sais pas peut-être le roi
bouge et que c'est compliqué
mais peut-être juste reprendre
peut-être possible de reprendre et
il y a un truc comme ça
sont pas mal ouais sonne pas de méga
envie de prendre aussi surtout que en
plus peut-être il y a des cailloux qui
peuvent marcher j'en sais rien donc donc
ça a l'air de se prémunir de ça
et ouais ce qu'elle est bien placé donc
faut 4 j'aime pas mal de la part de
Fabiano qui replace ce fou un peu la
défense de ce côté et qui blinde sa
position donc il se prémunit peut-être
de l'arrivée d'un four en dessin car
bien sûr les Noirs pourraient le faire
mais ça serait pour faire un échange et
puis pour taper sur G2 ça change un
petit peu les choses
et
voilà donc peut-être
peut-être que ça va pas trop mal pour
faire bien au final et qui va égaliser
cette position alors après bien sûr
combien il y a tellement de pièces
encore en jeu elles sont toutes là il y
a que deux pions échangés il peut se
passer bien de choses
après je sais pas si un coup comme c'est
vite peut-être très jouable un coup qui
me semble peut-être raisonnable cache le
fou
évite de se casser la tête avec des
problèmes aussi à chaque fois et voilà
ça a pas l'air de manger de manger de
pain ce coup au pire ça laisse cavalu
aussi pour échanger celui-là un jour
peut-être une option pour wesler on va
voir en tout cas c'est à lui de jouer
ici après faut 4 il a toujours pas réagi
toujours c'était car un peu de 2 minutes
et quelques
qui pourra peut-être compter en fin de
partie si les choses s'anime par la
suite et que ce genre manque de temps ça
peut paraître de mettre la pression
qu'on a j'en ai plus que 30 secondes et
que son adversaire on a entre deux et
trois
pas du tout non non Magnus a gagné
d'ailleurs sera le grand format de cette
journée son match contre
les matchs ici entre les potentiels
futurs vainqueurs du tournoi mais qui
ont déjà perdu un match
donc là voilà on s'y prend l'instant ce
match entre Westley saut et Fabian une
affiche de choix quand même match en
deux parties peut-être trois parties
d'ailleurs
puisque en cas de d'égalité donc soit
après deux matchs nuls soit s'il y a une
victoire chacun on a un le fameux
Armageddon avec les enchères vraiment la
spécificité de ce tournoi où les joueurs
en chérie et celui qui prend le moins de
temps aura le droit d'avoir les pièces
noires alors l'intérêt d'avoir les
pièces noires c'est que vous avez le
droit de faire nul et que ça gagne quand
même le match ce serait un petit peu
comme si au foot on disait avec une
équipe ne joue plus qu'à 10 ou 9 mais
qu'il y a que 10 minutes à jouer et
s'ils ont pas pris de but au port c'est
dit après c'est 10 minutes et ben ils
auraient gagné carrément le match même
sans marquer un but donc
voilà alors d'habitude on avait on
voyait ça plus dans des parties rapides
très rapides Blitz là non là c'est des
rapides avec un quart d'heure chacun
mais certains jours choisissent peu de
temps on a vu Wesley sceaux choisir 8
minutes 02 l'autre jour ou une minute 12
je sais plus exactement
mais c'était pas bien passé il est perdu
de manière expéditive malgré tout contre
abusa Torah
cela dit hier il a repris les pièces
noires il a gagné contre faites donc les
sauts joueurs très solide
il apprécie beaucoup jouer avec les
pièces noires et pouvoir blinder le jeu
même avec moitié moins de temps de son
adversaire vraiment un exploit de jouer
de manière aussi solide en si peu de
temps
et donc peut-être peut-être qu'on aura
le clou du spectacle etc une petite
heure c'est tout ce qu'on espère bien
évidemment
là il a joué donc food dessin qui pour
proposer les changes des fous et Fabiano
Carola qui vient de jouer dame
F3 pour soutenir un peu un peu sa
position
dame qui peut parfois bon qu'elle est
active évidemment enfin il y a des tours
ou quoi mais qui peut être peut-être
sujet à des attaques de ce cavaler alors
peut-être pas encore puisque les H4 il y
a du d'emprun F4 mais ça peut arriver
d'ailleurs la turbinette a l'air
pas tellement apprécié le coup
peut-être la qualité de l'air comment ça
s'est ressentir à Bienne qu'il y a quand
même tenu 19 coups de très belles
factures mais là 20e coup peut-être
promis signe que ce CO2 est un peu trop
présent dans la pièce manque d'oxygène
et il pourrait peut-être y avoir du
califran G2 bien sûr sur quel projet de
roi prend attention à la fourchette paf
paf le caillou H4 qui attaquerait et le
roi G2 et la dame F3 et sur quel projet
2 dames prends G2 peut-être du cavalier
H4 force la dame allait en H1 et avoir
après ce qui se passerait peut-être des
tours des F5 des coups comme ça
attention ça peut piquer peut-être ce
genre de variante
voilà turbinet t'aime pas trop on va
voir si wesleaux lui de son côté sans
compte alors malheureusement on peut pas
suivre la qualité de l'arche chez lui
est-ce que lui a mis toutes les
conditions de son côté ce qui ce qu'il a
vraiment tout fait pour être au top de
sa forme et pouvoir voir ce genre de
coup vraiment pas évident qu'elle y
prend G2
du radis du radis
peut-être que Wesley va se contenter
d'échanger le fond en quatre également
possible mais il renoncerait à
l'avantage en choisissant un tel coup
donc là on est vraiment crucial du match
on retient notre souffle est-ce que
Wesley va partir à l'offensive ou pas
contre le roi de Fabiano avec peut-être
des tactiques arrivant par la suite
en tout cas il réfléchit
c'est pas si bon signe signe qui vérifie
les variantes ou si il est plus en à la
recherche de plan qui ne sait pas
exactement quoi jouer elles viennent de
passer sous la barre des 5 minutes et il
échange en 4 voilà le coup le coup
peut-être plus attendu plus évident
c'était échange donc qui supprime le
foie de verre et qui commence à
simplifier la position
qui met en place son plan de jeu faire
des nuls et faire encore une nulle avec
les Noirs à l'Armageddon pour l'emporter
avec trois nuls
plan de jeu qui peut être très efficace
il l'a montré hier qu'on te fait de ses
rêves c'est ça vraiment spécialiste de
ces plans de match
donc il vient de prendre quatre parce
que Fabien va prendre la tour non il
prend du cavalier
il réduit les possibilités d'échange
adverse
et donc il y a quand même deux très
beaux cavaliers sans trop qui contrôle
énormément de cases un peu dessiner une
belle rosace offensive par là-bas
voilà toutes ces cases là ça fait de
beaux escaliers
plein de coups il y a pas péril dans la
demeure mais attention quand même à la
pendule
moins bientôt moins de 4 minutes
attention
et il choisit encore d'échanger supprime
le cahier des quatre il affiche un pion
isolé à son adversaire alors bien sûr il
a donné un fou pour la peine mais il va
se donner voilà une six potentielle avec
la tour là qui vient attaquer cette case
D5 sympa pour ses pièces normalement les
cavaliers qui pourraient virevolter
dessus
donc intéressant souvent dans ces
structures les blancs aiment bien voir
caisse blanche qui t'apprrais cette
diagonale mais il a été échangé on voit
toute la vie stade Wesley sceaux avec ce
coup D5 faut prendre 4 et donc échange
de foot case blanche adverse avant de
rentrer là-dedans et donc maintenant
qu'il y a plus de périnée dans la
demeure sur le pion F7 il change la
structure de pion
donc très instructif très instructif de
la part de Wesley de jouer ainsi
il replace donc ça tourne D8 qui a fait
son taf en 8 qui peut laisser la place à
l'autre tour qui pourra peut-être
doubler les tours sur la colonne D pour
attaquer ce pion et donc ce pion des 4
qui est une cible qui peut être attaquer
rapidement par un camion aussi on sait
qu'on a mis aussi bloqué peut-être ce
pion pour l'attaquer ultérieurement
donc ça Fabiano Caravana maintenant de
faire l'effort pour défendre dans cette
position mais on sait on sait que c'est
pas facile
je veux voir je surveille du coin de
l'oeil mais non il a toujours pas pu
améliorer la qualité de l'air sur ces
1066 ppm de CO2
qui est vraiment dans altérer sa faculté
à trouver les meilleurs coups
cela dit s'accroche il peut être en
manque d'oxygène un manque d'air un peu
comme si montait un col tel le vent tout
et pour l'instant il s'accroche il se
reste dans les roues derrière bien aidé
par ses équipiers ils jouent tours AD1
qui vient se placer pour pour défendre
ce pion et donc sur un coup sur comme
tout reprend des quatre qui semblera
gagner un pion et ben non il y a [__]
F4 découverte et on ne peut pas prendre
tout l'intérêt de secouage 3 ça fait que
le Roi peut se cacher ici et les blancs
resteraient avec une pièce enfin une
dame et une pièce contre deux tours donc
il y a pas de tout reprendre et 4 après
ce couteau radin donc de manière
astucieuse de défendre ce pion des
quatre
Wesley lui a rapidement jouécal aussi
intensifiant la pression sur ce pion
faible
et donc maintenant Satan à ce que
Fabiano doivent déplacer son fou d'un
côté ou de l'autre pour bien soutenir le
pion et continuer donc à défendre tout
en subissant quand même les coups de
bambou adverse attention
donc faut trois poussez trois on va voir
qu'elle va être le choix du champion
américain
comment il va défendre ce pion central
isolé il a choisi de venir en E3
donc il défend le pion il s'accroche
est-ce que Wesley ici dans la pression
double ramener ce qui est G6 qui était
très mêlanté dans un premier temps pour
défendre Laura et maintenant qu'il y a
plus trop de danger peut-être rebondir
au 7 pour venir faire un tour par ici ou
vers la case F5 ou il rattaquerai ce
pion s'il est soutenu par la suite
notamment par une tour en dessin
peut-être
on va voir ah ouais c'est de se décider
en tout cas il a quand même moins de
temps
tourne autour de 3 minutes 20
même si sa position est légèrement plus
agréable rien n'est fait rien n'est fait
le suspense est total dans cette partie
dans ce match
est-ce que Wesley va faire vaciller son
adversaire et prendre un net ascendant
on le sait il serait bien contenté d'une
nul mais là maintenant qu'il y a une
position comme ça
sans trop de risques et où il peut
presser il est complètement à son aise
il joue cavalier E7 donc un coup
utile ramène ce cavalier vers des cases
plus plus agressives pour attaquer
éventuellement ce pion donc l'alphabet
quoi jouer peut-être chercher du
contre-je un moment essayer d'affaiblir
les cases noires adverse parce que ce
recroque de spion ça pourrait un moment
rompre on sait que la stratégie de
roseau peut fonctionner pendant un
moment certains joueurs sont
spécialistes de la stratégie roseaux
telle cariakine et Fabiano c'est
peut-être moins son style je le verrai
plus essayer une contre-attaque partir
avec un pion là-bas vers l'avant ce sont
des contre-champs
sa fragiliserait l'option G7 pion
essentiel à l'édifice du rock noir et
donc sans ce pion voilà la case départ 6
sera affaiblie pour le cavalier
peut-être pour la dame encore mieux pour
les mater là-bas peut-être pour le fou
qui pourrait un moment revenir sur cette
diagonale voir donner un pion pour venir
ici donc ça pourrait tout d'un coup
faire tourner les événements
alors peut-être alors peut-être on va
voir
tout à fait nous qui réfléchit
cherche comment peut-être faire tourner
cette partie
il choisit plutôt cavalier C5 alors
Wesley immédiatement échanger ce
cavalier et donc oh je m'attendais une
reprise mais la petit coup intermédiaire
où il replace son fond en attaquant la
dame
qui va devoir bouger
et attention il faut quand même toujours
défendre ce qui avait lieu cette on peut
pas vraiment aller faire un tour par ici
sous peine de perdre du matériel
d'imbécis on aura envie de base pour
peut-être arrêter B2 mesdames B6 puis on
prend c'est 5 bêtement ou pas d'ailleurs
ou peut-être
sûrement sûrement très bien de reprendre
cette donc attention
il a fait quoi il a fait dams 8 alors
est-ce qu'on prend ici est-ce qu'on
prend le set les deux peut-être sont
possibles j'aurais tendance à aimer ce
coup de reprise en C5 puisque ça donne
une petite case des 6 pour rentrer plus
tard et surtout ça enlève ce pion isolé
c'est ce qu'il a choisi doit reprendre
un je pense qu'il reprend de la tour
mais peut-être de la dame si possible
pour maintenir une pression ici en tout
cas Wesley ce qui veut faire sûrement
c'est mettre le cavalier en dessin où il
sera central et bien soutenu par le pion
c'est 6 voilà après le cavalier
contrôlera beaucoup de cases et blindra
un peu la position évitant que les
Blancs puissent rentrer que ce soit sur
une colonne ou l'autre alors en dessin
physiquement pour la colonne D mais
aussi il contrôle la case de 7 et donc
une tour d'entrerait pas là haut donc
c'est plutôt une manière de blinder que
wesh choisit c'est plus vraiment pour
jouer une position pour l'avantage mais
simplement pour rester dans le contrôle
et ne pas perdre
toute la Fabiano bravo à lui même dans
des conditions dantesques avec beaucoup
de CO2 dans sa pièce il arrive quand
même à trouver les coups et à ne pas
subir l'impact positionnel de Wesley Sow
même c'est même lui qui viendra attaquer
peut-être ce pion à 5 un peu sur case
noir
et qui peut être maintenant une
faiblesse parce qu'il est désolidarisé
du reste de sa chaîne de pion qui serait
en A7 ou à 6 bien sûr ce serait très
solide ce serait compact là il est tout
seul le pion est attaqué attention
attention le pion ne peut pas avancer il
serait capturé par la dame donc il va
falloir le défendre avec un coup comme
d'hab c'est 7 ou dame D8 mais on n'aime
pas trop confier une tâche trop
défensive à la dame c'est un peu la
limite dans ses mouvements et dans tout
ce qu'elle pourrait faire
donc on va voir ce qu'il en est dame C7
choisi par Wesley damacat immédiatement
je pars fermé donc qui met la pression
maintenant sur son adversaire qui vient
attaquer le pion dans ma 4 donc il
attaque une seconde fois ce pion à 5 et
la tour 1 à 8
alors parfois la tour pour être Dévi
attention mettre du couloir pour
l'instant il faut prendre un 5 qui
serait une tentative de piège pour
dévier serait peut-être trop hâtif
puisque on resterait dans dans un
clouage mais c'est des thèmes tactiques
qui peuvent commencer à roder attention
donc
côté
Wesley la position tourne vinaigre j'ai
envie de dire alors il a joué toi vite
faut prendre à 5 ça gagne un pion juste
on reste dans un clouage mais cela dit
on pourrait le soutenir par BK donc
peut-être c'est une tentative au point 5
après avoir si on peut faire autre chose
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier mais
c'est vrai que maintenant on regrette
d'avoir ici il serait mieux si on avait
le choix si on a le droit de le jouer on
jouerait à 5 à 6 reculerait voir à 5 à 7
même on pourrait reculer de deux cases
alors keV revient pour ce moment
fatidique dans ce match j'ai quand même
une théorie à partager Fab ah ok j'ai
écouté tes commentaires dis-moi tout et
vu le niveau de jeu déployé par Fabiano
Carana je me demande si l'appareil est
dans sa pièce de jeu ça m'étonnerait
qu'avec un CO2 aussi élevé il puisse
déployer un tel niveau de jeu une telle
défense soit bien tu crois peut-être que
peut-être qu'il l'a placé ailleurs dans
sa cuisine et que c'est les casseroles
qui chauffent et exactement Fabien
est-ce que ça ne serait pas ça en
réalité ce ne serait pas du blog
que que sa qualité d'air et piètre parce
que comment comment pourrait-il calculer
aussi vite avec une pièce quand même
j'ai envie de dire inondé de CO2
assez humide enfin dans mon corps jamais
vu les 50% dépassé bah oui c'est
peut-être de l'eau qui bout en fait
ouais il y a aussi les 27 degrés donc ça
s'accumule CO2 trop élevé une humidité
quand même importante dans la pièce un
CO2 qui sature complètement l'oxygène
mais enfin bientôt qui réussit à jouer
les coups et là peut-être une tour qui
pourrait venir en D1 le pion B7 qui peut
tomber Fab ce pion à 5 qui est protégé
Fabiano qui est en train de faire un
récital je ne peux pas y croire non
c'est vrai mais j'étais un peu inquiet
pour lui
tu fais voilà des indicateurs qu'on
avait mais qui évidemment sont peut-être
tronqués et de sa position qui tenait
pas trop envie mais tout d'un coup après
ce cas ici 5 tout a bien tourné c'est
pas très pas trop aimé ce verbe tronquer
je parlerai plutôt de bluff de la part
de Fabiano
volontairement
voilà tu vois on doit animal qui écrit
c'est du bluff et oui Fabien il a bien
caché son jeu mais oui même un
commentateur avisé comme toi c'est fait
avoir un par ce jeu de dupe faudrait
qu'on puisse avoir des interviews des
joueurs peut-être voir
accès à la pièce pour pour se faire un
dernier avis mais c'est vrai qu'on
joindre tel sorte ça fait penser un
cycliste qui casse son jeu qui a l'air à
la peine carabinée
[Musique]
en quel groupe mais qui attend vraiment
le moment fatidique et là c'est un peu
ce qu'on est en train de vivre ouais
c'est les sauts qui à mon avis
ne va pas se faire avoir dans la
deuxième partie je pense qu'il est en
train de comprendre à quoi il a affaire
alors pourquoi pas demain arriver pour
Fabiano à 70% d'humidité 35 degrés
pourquoi pas mais plus personne ne croit
à son petit manège Fabien
c'est pas faux c'est pas faux
j'aurais sous la pluie apparemment
qui met la dame en E3
et attention qui est passé sous la
minute
qui est dans le rouge maintenant
ouais mais qui a un pion de moins alors
est-ce que c'est pion poire avancer
on verra mais quand même sympa il peut
il peut soutenir l'arrivée d'une tour
notamment D6 peut-être un moment et puis
peut-être on ferait assis après et
change B7 et on prendra ces 6 à la place
on aura un beau pion c'est passé donc je
pense quand même toujours mieux de
l'avoir pour soi que contre soi ce pion
C5 ça quand même une mauvaise nouvelle
d'avoir une victoire d'entrée ça
amenuiserait grandement les chances d'un
Armageddon et peut-être que dans l'autre
match ah oui peut-être espérons
espérons pas bien
il y a trois
tactique par par cavalier 2 c'est ça ça
donne des blagues dans le chat mais qui
sont pas forcément très très drôle
Fabien
non mais bon ça anime un petit peu tout
ça
elle paraît d'animer
pourraient se retrouver très affaibli
donc d'ailleurs il commence à couvrir un
peu avec ce coup j'ai étroit la case F4
F6 jouer à tempo la dame qui se décale
semble pas simple d'avancer avec les
Blancs
et réussi quand même à mettre un petit
peu la marche avant le cavalier qui qui
a ses cases coupé pour le moment tel un
Grégory
mais c'est pas facile
ça peut être dangereux dans l'autre sens
en tout cas il faut jouer en la sentir
mes formes ouais plutôt dans dans
ce tournoi et d'ailleurs il n'avait pas
allumé un son n'a pas accès à son
boîtier alors est-il réellement en train
de vérifier la qualité de son air ou pas
peut-être qu'en fait c'est même pas du
bluff pour Caravana mais juste peut-être
que western un air plus pourri c'est
encore pire ça expliquerait c'est
mauvais coup à jouer depuis le début de
la compétition et bien évidemment
la 5 jeux il veut sur mon Dom G6 et H6
non il recule
joue un petit peu vite il essaye de
faire tomber Wesley qui avait des
problèmes de connexion aussi au-delà des
peut-être de problème respiratoires
s'accumule ça cumule
50 secondes pour Faby qui est pas parti
sur le DAB G6 H6 qui paraissait quand
même très logique non
[Musique]
on ne sait pas
des deux cavaliers F6 qui revient il
revient vers E4 ça y est il est en train
de trouver cette belle case là
tout se joue maintenant
on espère quand même la nul Fabien qui
nous approcherait de cette Armageddon ah
bah oui le moment
finalement je sais pas c'est tout ce
qu'on aime dans un
quoi peut-être faire que des arbres pour
la prochaine fois non c'est quand même
bien qu'on voit un petit peu avant ce
qui se passe
Armageddon en fait c'est un peu à la fin
mais les joueurs doivent s'apprivoiser
qu'on voit un peu la dynamique du match
avant pendant peut-être 4-5 heures avant
cet Armageddon final ou là voilà les
joueurs vont être en pleine possession
de leur manière ou toutes les infos sur
répertoire adverse la forme du moment
etc et pour en choisir en fonction
finalement quel enchères faire à la
seconde près et là être voilà être très
bien quoi en vrai la plénitude de la
compétition quelque part j'ai envie de
dire exactement alors voici en tout cas
qui a remangé un pion et là il nous
colle un échec
oh il a pas l'air bien Fabiano il a pas
l'air bien et il revient d'ailleurs avec
son roi oh attention ça pourrait être la
correctionnelle le cavalier qui va
arriver en Détroit Fabien au mi Adam
prend F5 échecs
que ça donnait mais le roi va aller trop
vite en F4 et prendre F5 donc on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas il va courir ta gym
jusqu'à ce pion F5
et peut-être qu'en fait les blancs vont
beaucoup de mal à s'enlever de ce de ce
clouage
tu vois je mortelle peut-être peut-être
il y a pas de maths pour l'instant ça
défend et que c'est Dame 3 qui est bien
là final de dames avec peu de temps la
pendule tout peut se passer au final est
complexe quand même parce que même au
cas où on échangerait les pions sont
finalement quelque part
il y a l'option s'est passé alors il a
pas échangé en F2 il se fait
contre-attaquer attention alors
contre-attaquer peut-être mais est-ce
que est-ce que le pion B7 tombe ou pas
peut-être pas parce qu'il y a du dame 5
échecs qui traînent d'âme c'est un tout
petit
allez faut peut-être pousser
il aurait pu hein commencer à jouer ces
quatre
il va peut-être l'envoyer
il fait G5 j'ai 5 un peu étonnant mais
il veut
le Roi
peut jouer le gain
ce cavalier est quand même dangereux
oh j'ai 5 attention on n'a pas vu oh là
là là terrible hein c'était quand même
pas très dur allez faut avancer côté ah
il veut pas avancer pour pas donner la
case des quatre qui prend ce pion un
petit peu anecdotique
mais il y a pas d'échec et pourquoi pas
ces quatre peut-être maintenant il faut
des quatre parties avec le roi de
l'autre côté ouais j'ai l'impression que
c'est Wesley qui va s'imposer après je
sais pas quand tu parles l'autre côté on
perd quand même G5 d'ailleurs il vient
attaquer G5
Fabien il va tout défendre
attention un dame E5 qui vient même
contrôler les cases attention de pas se
prendre un cavalieux à un moment donné
j'ai un peu peur pour fabieno quand même
ouais là la position en train de mal
tourner pour lui le cahier qui revient
en F4 ça y est il commence à être
dominant
[Applaudissements]
quel spectacle hein Fabien dès ce début
de journée
poursuivre la compétition des dès le
début de journée Fabien parce que là on
a affaire on a le droit à mano Amano
assez exceptionnel les deux joueurs se
rendent coup pour coup
et bien malin qui dira celui qui va
remporter ce match en tout cas Fabiano
qui recule recule mais n'auront pas
c'est maintenant lui dans le rôle du
chasser
et ouais c'est dans le rôle du chasseur
le prédateur tel un chat
il veut peut-être monter le roi vers B3
si peu attention attention il y a le fou
qui peut connecter
Dame des 7 est-ce qu'il y aurait pas un
genre de perpétuelle ici avec dams et 4
et peut-être et d'un meuf 7 le retour il
va falloir jouer ta mecs côté Wesley
ça va être tendu
les deux joueurs qui donnent vraiment
tout pour le gain ils ont répété il
fallait refuser de répéter et l'un et
l'autre alors peut-être rentrer dans la
finale au final et ramener le roi vite
en C2
c'est pas fait attention pas d'un
Français trois sur un mat avec
[Musique]
une dame B5 et chaque courroie
sur les dames ranger 5 ou
c'est chaud il va essayer de répéter
et ce qui va partir pour du cavalier
aussi
c'est pas moins dangereux Fabien
elle rends un peu explosé mais bon
d'après France c'est pas évite aussi
dans l'autre sens ça y est il a mis ce
cavalier en E6
la richesse il part en C5
s'il trouve refuge pour son roi le pion
c'est va être trop fort
il a l'air d'aller se cacher il va aller
vers assis à 7 à 8 peut-être et puis
oh que oui parce que oh là là c'est
terminé
sur la qualité de l'air était juste hein
c'était peut-être pas du bluff et bien
joué à Wesley qui a vraiment joué
là-dessus facteur déterminant ce match
en CO2 bien trop élevé et ça lui coûte
probablement la partie Fabien ah bah
c'est sûrement ça alors dans l'autre
match ce qui s'est passé entre les
théories de Saga et Eleven
on va on va le voir tout de suite Fabien
avant la pause on va vous donner le
résultat avec une victoire du Tour
ridsaïa c'est senior bravo à lui deux
victoires avec les Noirs dans dans ce
début de match et on va se retrouver
très bientôt Fabien pour la suite du
tournoi avec le partenaire évidemment
msses mces télécharge tes parties
et
les informations sur sur ce que tu dois
jouer les facteurs ou progresser à tout
de suite mesdames et messieurs après
cette petite pause petite respiration
[Musique]
et on est de retour mesdames et
messieurs évidemment pour ce match
retour on espère un réellement une
victoire de Fabiano
pas bien parce qu'on a eu une défaite de
Levon donc il tourise Zaga qui avait
besoin qui va avoir besoin simplement
d'un match nul pour s'assurer
une qualification et de l'autre côté Fab
on suit aussi donc on pourrait ne pas
avoir le droit à l'Armageddon qui nous
semblait promis et ouais malheureusement
mais écoute peut-être livonne aussi peut
quand même gagner avec les noirs on
verra dans ce muscuin donc Fabienne ok
l'air de repartir ce méthode risque
comme hier Magnus qui est arrivé à
contrecarrer incroyable c'est vraiment
on ne voit pas ça souvent ouverture si
forte
qui ne gagne pas et donc aujourd'hui il
retente quand même il sait que c'est
quand même très fort comme ouverture et
qu'il a les les stats avec lui en jouant
ainsi et donc il essaye donc restez
forcément un prix au dépourvu déjà une
minute dès le troisième coup est-ce que
il voit venir son adversaire le
stratagème
d'antijeux
même si hier Fabiano avait quand même
cassé un petit peu les règles en jouant
un B5 avant un petit rock qu'on a pas
l'habitude de voir dans cette ouverture
j'ai envie de te dire c'est peut-être un
petit manque d'expérience de Fabiano oui
en tout cas il a mis le pion assis
immédiatement
avec voilà donc menace de risque
d'ailleurs bon westler empêché B5
peut-être dû l'accueillir plutôt parce
que là on va Fabiano qui met vraiment en
place le schéma parfait ça joue à la
perfection à côté à côté Fabiano il met
en place la méthode
pas mieux jouer pour le moment côté noir
peut-être un coup comme eux si si
intéressant
c'est rare à ce niveau là de d'utiliser
cette arme secrète
je disais que par les plus grands
partis quasiment sans suspense sa Fabien
voilà je pense qu'on se dirige tout
droit vers l'armée
déjà net ascendant après la pendule une
minute d'avance
évidemment Fabien mais ouais c'est qui a
raison de laisser égrainer le temps
parce que la cavalier 7 va arriver ou
fou baisser vous pouvez ça être
peut-être même six tout de suite mettre
en place la carapace et je suis vraiment
inquiet pour
pour Wesley là il y a beaucoup de bons
coups en cavalier E7 cavalier D7 fou B7
h6 il a l'embarras du choix
sur les diagonales donc là les Blancs
jouent normalement mais ils vont être
bientôt prise au piège la toile
d'araignée noire n'ayant aucun plan à
faire valoir
telle chose j'ai peur Fabien aussi qui
soit tenté de mettre le Cavaillon F6
quand même la stratégie
7 et 7
ce qui serait une grave erreur c'est
risqué
tout d'un coup bon peut-être la
l'ouverture perd de sa puissance
de certains aussi fréquent le 7 qui a
été 7 H6 c'est l'erreur petit rock
surtout pas surtout pas ok
il faut vraiment mettre en place la
tactique
dite d'antiges Fabien
si les blancs veulent à un moment
essayer de casser la position au centre
être là et fermer immédiatement pour ne
pas laisser l'adversaire ouvrir
et donc se casser les dents sur cette
sur cette noix quelle
est pour une interdiction de cette
méthode en tournoi je crois que c'est
déjà le cas bon là ils ont de la chance
c'est un tournoi ils jouent à domicile
et ils ont pas d'arbitre dans le dos ils
peuvent se permettre ce genre de choses
mais
quand même être tournois fille avec des
arbitres
internationaux
l'ampleur du problème
il ne peut rien faire ouais c'est pris
dans les taux
de qualité
F3 KFC 3 n'est pas non plus trop bien ce
qu'attendent les Noirs dans le genre de
situation et essaie peut-être de
brouiller les pistes avec ce camion des
deux un peu comme magnussy hier
peut-être pour aller ensuite en F1 une
fois que tu auras bougé et puis en G3 et
peut-être pousser le pion h
donc moi je suis inquiet qui repartent
sur une erreur un peu comme hier de
mettre le cavalier sur une nouvelle case
et mis le pion en B5 finalement non non
faut pas être trop créatif dans cette
ouverture il faut vraiment suivre à la
lettre
et c'est la garantie ensuite d'avoir de
beaux résultats
je suis inquiet Fabien pour pour Fabiano
j'ai l'impression qu'il n'a pas les
connaissances nécessaires ici
étonnant étonnant
de la théorie mais peut-être cette
histoire de CO2 qui brouille sa mémoire
aussi enfin voilà bon il a quand même
après réflexion
donc là on le rappelle un petit rock
c'est une énorme faute
oh là là oh là là
à ce niveau de la compétition Fabien il
ne maîtrise pas l'ouverture
j'espère encore peut-être que Wesley
poussin pion au sang pour en mettre en
place l'antijeux et peut-être le
rastrait pas si mal mais normalement
voilà vraiment c'est pas du tout
conseillé on veut faire un 6 oh là là il
fait ces cinq avant d'avoir 1000
cavaliers en 17 ouais bon c'est terrible
il n'y a pas l'option h6 il y a trop
trop d'erreurs commises là parfois bien
non
à mon avis il ne pourra pas l'emporter
dans cette partie Fabien
voilà je crois qu'il va pas vouloir
mettre le quai en dessin tu veux les
faire pression sur des 4 en fait on va
faire c'est prendre
les leçons de ça des fêtes d'hier il a
peut-être même une autre idée hein
un échange avec un Pione en face alors
on attend la poussée de pion blanc pour
contre
l'ouverture de cette position
mais bon ça on trouve ça que dans
certains grimoires
au lieu de fermer le jeu d'être dans un
anti-vieux il ouvre le jeu et il invite
au jeu
bah d'ailleurs voilà ça permet à Wesley
d'ouvrir la position et d'interdire la
remise
certains pensent
vous étiez même pas reprendre le pion
finalement écœuré
il hésite sur comment reprendre
c'est trop tard pour hésiter Fabien les
erreurs ont été faites plutôt mais ça
peut-être qu'ils ne le sait pas mais
forcément il le sent à son niveau il
doit savoir que que son niveau de jeu
n'est pas optimal pour pour le moment
et qui joue en réalité relativement mal
dans cette partie Fabien
le petit rock le coussin
les erreurs qui sont multipliées
on l'a senti un moment au moment du
petit rock on a on a on a vraiment senti
que la partie prenait une mauvaise
direction pour Fabiano voilà un cours
vraiment trop classique
alors qu'elle se ressentent quand même
tu laisses l'adversaire
dans l'Embar il le sait pas tu vas à
droite tu vas à gauche tu vois ce centre
il ne sait plus
là maintenant il sait là là il a montré
ses cartes
elle a dévoilé son jeu et ce pion qui
restait sur la case 7
du couloir qui venait arriver
les deux erreurs se prématérialisées
l'absence depuis en H6 qui aura dans la
case
du couloir c'est quand même déjà une
défense redoutable et robuste rien que
pour ça
la position serait toujours fermée de
toute façon c'est suivi les préceptes je
ne comprends pas comment la colonne D a
pu a pu s'ouvrir Fabien
étonnant quand même on parle d'un joueur
qui a été numéro 2 mondial et finissent
du champion du monde mais oui mais
il y a peut-être pas
encore toutes de cette magie noire de la
ruse
hier Magnus Carsen semblait maîtriser
avec les Blancs
du coup très impressionnant c'est pas
trop
par quel bout aller le chercher
même la Ruiz reste muette face à un tel
joueur
mais bon c'était une semi-rouise quand
même disons-le puis en B5 déjà il y
avait des provoqué par Manu ça on voit
que Wesley a joué à 4 de dire à
provoquer B5 et oui ça fait que Magnus
l'a laissé faire
encore une fragilité dans le camp
adverse
qu'il a su exploiter avec Maestra
de 5 oui évidemment maintenant qu'il y a
plus de pions des 6 il y a plus
l'antijeux
ici et ça serait très important pour
prendre la caisse de 4 pour pas que le
cavalier Vienne bondir dessus là
clairement osla il veut qu'il y avait le
4 il veut des cases qui normalement ne
sont pas disponibles
beaucoup trop d'erreurs ont été commises
par
Fabiano caroanna avec les pièces noires
faudrait la réussite comme on dit dans
le chat tu as baissé l'humidité 1 2 3 %
mais toujours ce 27 degrés hein qui
reste il reste bloqué à 27 degrés
mais le CO2 qui qui ne descend pas en
dessous des
1000 ça ce sont des détails qui qui
coûtent cher pour pour Fabiano et la
regarde le cavalier qui va arriver en E4
il n'aurait jamais dû atterrir sur cette
case
et on comprend aussi pourquoi ces
joueurs sont finalement dans le loser
bracket le tableau des perdants des
loosers
finalement on voit la différence entre
justement le winner bracket qui maîtrise
la Ruiz ceux qui ne maîtrise pas
exactement
c'est pas étonnant que baisser les
règles ne comprend rien aux échecs
mais sûrement fatigué de devoir
expliquer réexpliquer cette méthode Ruiz
pourtant on se sent pas trop dur à
maîtriser de prime abord
s d'antiges de non rock
on sait que petrociane maîtrisé cette
cette défense est devenue champion du
monde et oui il est arrivé
je crois que c'est dans le match de
1966 parce qu'il y avait essayé
et je pense c'est l'apanage des
champions du monde finalement de
maîtriser
complètement je rappelle que oui il
avait tenté contre mvl
son succès sans succès
dépose
une excellente nouvelle de MLS nous
avons une égalisation à venir pour aller
vannes à rognan
alors c'est loin d'être fait encore mais
en E3 les cases noires qui sont
défoncées le fouet fin qui va jamais
sortir c'est vrai que tu peux jouer tout
le sur les lames le feu fin c'est un
[__] de plomb
peut-être de faire H5 ça bouge plus
jamais quoi et tu joues avec un fou de
plus
rien je préfère quand tu me parles en
Ruiz
complexe quand même monsieur
donc
le fou de devient une sorte de poids
dans la position je comprends tout à
fait ouais et ce pion que fait-il en H4
devrait être en H3 finalement peut-être
même faire G4 un moment pour se délivrer
et là bon
mais bon le pion elle doit être en C2 B3
à 3
mais peut-être H5 donc chez Les Vans
pour cloisonner tout ça alors peut-être
les blancs devront donner une pièce on
verra bien
et retournons peut-être chez Fabiano
donc il va arriver ce cavalier local se
font F4 peut-être des pièces en G5 aussi
une case normalement qu'on doit
contrôler
il réfléchit de façon il sait pas quoi
faire
c'est dur parce que
tout d'un coup prend un petit peu l'eau
car ça ton expertise on comprend les
enjeux on comprend pourquoi ça a mal
tourné
il n'a pas maîtrisé la magie noire
ruizasque
mais bon ça donne quand même
des axes de travail et peut-être
des idées pour aller peut-être chercher
le titre mondial qui manque à son
palmarès
doit bien rigoler de chez lui deux
semaines bon d'un tournoi mineur qui est
la Coupe du Monde finalement Maxime un
peu en dessous on le dit depuis
plusieurs années depuis deux trois ans
il est plus à sa meilleure forme
évidemment il est pas qualifié pour ce
tournoi merci merci
je crois qu'il voyage à droite à gauche
dans le monde
mais ça lui donne évidemment de
sérieuses indications par rapport à
Fabiano si le rencontrer en Coupe du
Monde il éventuel faiblesse peut-être
à exploiter
surtout que le pic de forme de Fabiano
sera passée après le grand chasse sourd
et surtout ce hasing Masters peut-être
qu'il est misé sur un pic de forme sur
le 3 ou 4e jour plutôt quatrième jour
d'ailleurs 4e jour et là il est
peut-être pas encore à 100%
et ça pourrait lui être fatale
de transmission de virus
avec un CO2 saturé dans la pièce
de Fabiano
peut-être une grippe qui qui sait
déclaré
parce que ça fait plusieurs jours qu'il
a
un CO2 qui sature
sa pièce n'est pas assez aérée ça
augmente après si il est seul ça doit
aller dans le même
jamais jamais trop prudent Fabien
peut-être on va mettre un masque alors
un
plus efficace effectivement
afin de se protéger
on espère politique dans laquelle il
joue
27 degrés c'est vrai qu'il faut aussi
chômer l'humidité qui baisse
l'humidité qui baisse petit à petit ce
sont tous des 50% maintenant attention
de pas aller vers zéro non plus c'est
trop sec
finalement quel est le
quelle quantité d'humidité adéquate
55 par là Fabien je suis pas spécialiste
de l'humilité mais ce que je vois c'est
que c'est vert et que ça baisse
je voudrais savoir sur tout le CO2 là
c'est
la température
[Musique]
et ses cinq serait contrés par dame
principe
donc pas évident qui arrive en 6
s'incruster en plein cœur de la position
noire
cette pieuvre pieuvre des 6
qui voilà
on n'aurait pas pu être là normalement
il y a un pion
participe à ces tournois
il a été champion du monde mais il
essaye quand même d'avoir
quand même participé à
ce tournoi
M6 rapide
alors qu'il a pris en dessin qui fait
aussi
sacrifice de qualité mais fort puisqu'il
va avoir une découverte mortelle après
puis on prend dame prend aussi ses
chèques roi chute cavalier F7 et full
français 7
du coup il ne faut pas prendre soupe
aussi
puis on continue ça marche en avant sans
parler d'éventuelles découvertes du
cavalier et ça a l'air fini pour les
espoirs de fabieno c'était pas trompé
Fabien quand on vous avait dit que que
Fabiano ne maîtrisait pas son ouverture
vous avez pas menti on est quand même
deux grands spécialistes de la méthode
Ruiz j'avais joué en tournoi bon voilà
ça t'avait pas valu de de bananes à la
fuite mais comme il remonte en mais
j'avais la chance un peu de jouer sur
des tal reculer comme j'avais fait nul
ta Troncin ou je sais plus un peu avant
j'avais quitté les tables un peu
retransmises et un peu caché
en arrière de la salle dans la pénombre
j'avais pu tromper la vigilance
arbitrale mais
bons montrant ça
non c'est vrai que je la chance de
tomber sur les arbitres Clément mais
j'ai pas pu renouveler donc l'expérience
depuis et je suis surveillant
une ruidifie plus voilà ça va être une
pièce de plus pour pour Fabiano
de sa partie
d'avant c'était vraiment passionnante
avec vraiment la partie qui allait dans
tous les sens Fabiano qui a refusé la
nuit lui-même puisseau etc
peu de temps voilà là celle là j'ai
l'impression que ça a été quand même
vraiment que dans un sens et donc tu es
jamais content de de perdre comme ça
puis sortir de ce tournoi
une grosse déception surtout que il a
fait des erreurs quand même assez
évidentes
notamment ce petit rock
alors qu'on a le site
vous pouvez le revoir
je choisis Dame des Saad donc pour
sortir du vis-à-vis face au fou G3 mais
après puis on prend les fuites il y aura
juste une pièce de plus
j'espère peut-être encore fermé ce qui
est dessiné
ce qui serait très optimiste mais bon
je crois que c'est bon
de plus et bientôt de pions
il y a pas de coup
on a pu croire un bluff de côté Fabiano
pendant un moment
mais là
sur la fin de cette première partie sur
celle-ci dans son ensemble
mais il y en a pas
le
foie de verse
mais qui arrive pas à prendre ton
initiative de l'autre côté pour le
moment ça pourrait être la très très
mauvaise nouvelle
c'est pas faux
on peut imaginer une
moment sans
armag et de
ce serait quand même dommage
ce serait assez terrible oui
effectivement
mais il le fait chaque jour non il en
avait vu
la fin de l'autre partie
je crois qu'elle est terminée
avec ce petit rat qui se C5
qui a vraiment ouvert le jeu et
l'accès à la caisse des 6 pour ce qui
avait les blancs donc bravo à Wesley zoo
qui a vraiment bien joué
on sait quand même la trempe d'un
champion du monde vu qu'il a été
champion du monde de chess 960 c'est pas
tout à fait le même jeu mais on sent
quand même une certaine puissance
à la fois tactique et stratégie
et donc à cette partie avec les Van
notre seul espoir de peut-être assister
à vos armagides noires et pour l'instant
l'égalité matérielle mais donc tout son
espoir réside dans ce fout G2 qui est
complètement enfermé c'est-à-dire qu'il
peut leur H3 il peut l'enlever deux il
peut aller en F1 il pourrait même aller
en H1 s'il le souhaitait mais rien de
plus donc c'est une pièce qui peut être
manquante de l'autre côté si le jeu se
transportait à les lames et ça va être
finalement la stratégie qui va essayer
de mettre en place pour petit à petit
aller côté Adam et jouer donc avec une
pièce de plus par là-bas
encore loin d'être le cas
pour l'instant il y a beaucoup de monde
les dames côté blanc il y a aussi un
avantage d'espace donc c'est pas facile
pour une erreur de circuler de ce côté
mais qui c'est petit à petit
il fait fout des 8
il va essayer
de 3 G7 puis toi H6 c'est coulisser
à quoi il pense hein
ça va être un jeu de manœuvre il y a un
moment ça va s'accélérer quand ça
passera aux choses sérieuses
en tout cas
le truc qui pourrait envisager de faire
mais jamais le faire pour l'instant en
tout cas c'est d'aller sacrifier une
pièce en dessin pour avoir deux pions et
des pions passés mais là c'est pas du
tout son terrain ni dans le dans le
match ni même dans la position ce serait
un peu trop tôt il y a trop de pièces et
puis on passait avoir du mal à avancer
et on rappelle qu'il joue avec une quasi
pièces de moins donc si on donne une
seconde
j'espère que le bon et aller à l'armée
on espère fort
55 ou 11 3 10
refait Dame des 7 ce petit moment de
yoyo de la dame
la pression sur
ça donne aussi éventuellement la Casa 6
au fou par la même occasion la casse C4
peut-être
tu reviens en C3
un problème de fois 6 pour l'instant si
tu veux faire qualit prend des cinq je
vais sur le clouage
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
c'est vrai que j'ai 5 tout d'un coup
voilà on rejoint côté droit
et c'est peut-être très fort d'ailleurs
moi j'aurais été tellement content de se
fouger de cloisonné que j'aurais essayé
de passer de l'autre côté pendant un
moment si je vois que j'arrive pas à me
dire on va faire l'autre rupture là-bas
ce qui se passe même si il joue plus
passera de l'autre côté j'ai
l'impression qu'il va peut-être
malheureusement pour nous un spectateur
se qualifier
solide pour le moment
mais là on peut pas quand même si x 6
plans pour défendre de l'autre côté
particulière très longtemps ces gens de
position fermée ça peut manœuvrer
ça peut dépasser la centaine de coups
assez facilement
extraordinaire même si même si il y a
pas beaucoup de coup de pied possible
j'ai envie de dire avec
ce format on a envie il y a des rajouts
250 coups même attention quand même les
vannes qui veut peut-être faire G5 ça va
faire bouger les choses peut-être pas
aller au 250 coups comme ça
plus possible sans une position de garde
tranchée comme on a eu là depuis un
petit moment
donc le dernier coup de pion jouet
c'était au coup 31 alors s'ils arrivent
81 sans rien bouger pour avoir une nul
avant
qui arrivent maintenant
c'est joli mais en fait il est un peu
tout seul il ne reste pas grand chose
donc sûrement que les Van va chercher
cette poussée G5
très prochainement sourire la colonne
g et allez pigeonner ce pion G3
allez arracher cette araignée donc on
attend tous
pour notre plus grand plaisir
il le fait pas
imbécile
il m'a pas l'air d'être très confiant
dans ce qu'il fait
ils ont à force de pas frapper
un jour
pas tout de suite
quand il fait un aller-retour mais là
c'est plus trois secondes quand même ça
fait une différence
elle peut échanger une tour repartir
vers B8
il peut prendre D8 et prendre C6 il va
pas le faire
de la partie pour l'instant dès que tu
es des opportunités comme ça mais alors
qu'elle est aussi il s'infiltre ça sort
d'un point il va prendre D8 mais je sais
pas qui ça favorise tout ça parce qu'il
reste faut je crois de toute façon qui
est le point là
ça c'est une autre histoire si on perd
ses 6 on s'appelle l'édifice de la
position peut-être une déception pour
nous Kevin
c'est bien un père il y a à Tourcoing FC
ici ouais si tu finis la partie
la désillusionner la Tour Eiffel
assez dame si c'est toi G8
Victor is Zaga qui se qualifie bon bravo
à lui on aurait préféré l'Armageddon
mais
c'est ainsi donc on va faire la petite
pause et donc se retrouver pour la
finale du Winner Bracket entre
Abdou satorov et manuscrite 19h je pense
on reste à l'affût à tout de suite
[Musique]
les amis de manière complètement
inattendue
ça a commencé on avance en réalité
Marc le premier match avait commencé en
retard ça fait un peu prendre de vitesse
par femme heureusement on a tout de
suite
vu toujours su en fait on a un compte
spécial pour pouvoir suivre en direct
ici on a un petit peu en différé
franchement on a vérifié à 19h ça
commençait à 18h59 Fab
20 minutes de retard pour le premier
match une minute d'avance pour le
deuxième
en réalité peut-être enfin
[Musique]
en tout cas personne de Fort l'utilise
non enfin
tous les forts à qui j'ai demandé
l'utilise pas voilà et peut-être des
fois qu'il utilise mais
méthode de péker je rappelle c'est de
refaire les mêmes exercices en boucle
non mais baquets il y a un truc pas mal
et dit en fait les échecs c'est toujours
les mêmes schéma qui reviennent du coup
c'est pas obligé de les faire en boucle
tu peux juste faire des exercices et
puis de toute façon tu sur ton bras
dessus
pour toi de ce match moi je mettrai tout
ça tu auras quand même
je sais pas gagner assez facilement ces
deux matchs sans forcer donc on va voir
là s'il va être poussé dans ses
retranchements pour pour ce match là
on va avoir le Fab
intéressant en tout cas
important
toute la magie qui a une meilleure
structure de pion
qui pourrait un retard de développement
ouais mais bon je crois que c'est pas
très grave
pour eux peut-être un jour essayer le
pion C4 alors peut-être changer son
fusil d'épaule et se pion c'est 6 le
passé en C5
et pour fixer ce pion C4 et après
peut-être qu'il y a ici peut-être B6 x 6
comme ça on verra
voilà c'est 5 donc il fixe le pion c'est
4 donc
ce qu'on peut appeler ça une fixade à
complètement je crois que c'est le terme
approprié et technique
on va fixe
maintenant dans la position pour lui
donc il faut prendre des décisions
en adéquation avec la position
attends je vois qu'une [__] parce que
il faut que je remette au premier à deux
points et demi
parce que maintenant on est dans le dans
le winner bracket
et ça il faut bien rappeler la
différence de règles dans chez les
loosers c'est en deux parties gagnantes
chez les Winners c'est 4 parties donc il
y a des petits même merde je sais pas
que c'est pas la finale carrément c'est
pas un demi de trop j'en sais rien je
sais honnêtement je sais pas je sais pas
comment calculer ça pour moi c'est la
demi-finale quand même
parce que si tu gagnes tu seras en
finale de winner
c'est vrai que c'est dur les
appellations ce schéma double bracket
moi je suis pour tenté le triple bracket
personnellement
en dessous tu te permet de peut-être
remonter la surface
pourquoi s'arrêter à deux en fait c'est
vrai que c'est un peu dommage
en tout cas ça joue
on va pouvoir se délecter de ce match
pour moi si à gagne ici on pourra
quasiment dire qu'il est champion du
monde d'échecs
dans un tournoi aussi prestigieux
après le grand test c'est
malgré tout
alors il a joué F4
joli coup
mais moi emballé par ce match mais c'est
vrai qu'on a vécu quand même un moment
tellement intense de sport avant
[Musique]
il y a que deux parties donc là
forcément il y avait le couperet qui
tombait là 4 tu te dis bon quoi qu'il
arrive dans cette partie
on a encore le temps
[Musique]
Magnus qui doit réfléchir
où mettre peut-être le calibre B8 un
consortirait bien donc qu'est-ce qu'on
Cessy c'est ce qu'on est d'avoir pu
tourner en 17 moins exposé mais qui
bloque un peu le fossé vite
il choisit des 7
centrale il va peut-être essayer
d'enchaîner avec E5 côté noir pour fixer
ce centre et donc ensuite
aller attaquer le pion c'est 4 le fameux
qui est
une cible
le genre en fait de plomb qu'on voit
beaucoup plus souvent dans indiennes que
dans dans des est indiennes qui étaient
en fait le
le début de cette partie mais on sait
que Magnus est un joueur quand même très
érudit et qui
connaît un peu toutes les structures et
donc lui ça va pas lui échapper genre
d'idée donc si il peut il va y aller
on va attendre allez c'est la partie
tranquillement se dérouler Fabien bon on
attend de voir on va jouer
qui suit des grandes lignes théoriques
et Magnus qui fait jouer son adversaire
le fait travailler très tôt dans la
partie
malheureusement on n'a pas la qualité de
son air
bon je ne sais pas on ne sait pas du
tout ce qu'il en est
malheureusement
l'information qui manque Fabien
truc pas évident pour les blancs pour
trouver un coup là on voit que c'est
beaucoup il joue fou G5 il redéplace le
fou pour attaquer le pion E7 alors bon
qui peut être descendu
sur cette case pour 8 devrait être
possible a priori
le coup
[Musique]
le coussin
joli
on attend Fabien
les échecs pas grand chose à faire
d'autre
que d'attendre dans cette partie
un tournoi quand même qui tient toutes
ses promesses
ah voilà on a quand même une première
finale de rêve
on peut être une seconde encore plus
grandiose ou encore la même mais dans
nos différentes conditions donc
on monte crescendo en puissance
spectacle est au rendez-vous
dommage qu'il y en ait que 600 de ces
champions de chaise tours par an
j'aurais bien aimé en voir au moins 12
[Musique]
0 mineurs autour
et donc elles ont pas le temps quand il
y a des Norvège des coupes du monde
[Musique]
autour qui parasite et qui empêche la
bonne tenue de cette tournure tout au
long de l'année ou peut-être bon un par
mois ce serait quand même un minimum
pourquoi pas deux trois
on se rend fou quoi
très beau quoi
avec les mêmes tout le temps
c'est marrant quand même
j'ai l'impression qu'il se fait défoncer
là
il place ses pièces et puis on va voir
mais le voilà le pion c'est 4 très vite
identifié de toute façon dans cette
structure qui est un problème pour
adoucator il faudra arriver à
créer du jeu quelque part ailleurs il va
se faire gober tout cru comme ça
ils veulent pas le pouvoir
je crois qu'il l'a pas très bien mangé
en fait comment il pouvait savoir que
mangerait pas de faim mais il est con
enfin lui il fait ce qu'il peut mais
en fait il l'a pâture
et il va il va se dissoudre mais il est
complètement con c'est qu'on finit en
fait je pense c'est leur but ultime
c'est de bouffer un mec qui
essayent ils essaient et là il en a un
et le mec c'est même pas le manger quoi
c'est terrible
ce que tu aimes B5 c'est nul ça pas une
bonne tête déjà dame français 3 mais
pierre d'échange
et cavalier à 4 peut-être
et Machin et tu vas te faire
mais peut-être jouable
mais c'est déjà pas facile
la position à temps et Magnus il se met
en place tranquille ou
dynamiter exactement
ça permet de garder la structure en
place et de faire [__] au prochain
mais
aussi puisque en fait en 4K le pion C3
évite que les gens fassent à 4 pour
renforcer en structure et prendre de
l'espace et ensuite le foget7 va taper
sur ce centre un fou de l'eau Feld pour
le coup
c'est bien je crois que c'est deux
belles options je sais pas quelle est la
meilleure mais dans les deux cas c'est
très bien
quelle partie extraordinaire Fabien
en attendant
quel spectacle quel spectacle mesdames
et messieurs on ne s'en lassera jamais
comme anus qui réfléchit aux deux
options voilà il va chercher à choisir
la meilleure celle qui lui plaît le plus
et qui va être le plus danger son jeune
adversaire
il a juste de prendre ta variante car il
est à 4 à mon avis
c'est logique fait tu vas empêcher
l'arrivée du pion à 4
et voilà c'est chose faite
complexe
en tout cas pour l'instant comme les
adversaires précédents de Magnus
complètement out plié
donc belle position pour Magnus en tout
cas qui peut faire mal d'entrée avec les
pièces noires
au dessus de ce tournoi mais bon voyons
voir s'il va quand même gagner cette
partie et continuer sur cette lancée
pour la suite du match
on verra bien
c'était une mauvaise nouvelle pour une
victoire avec les Noirs là d'entrée
dans le petit
après peut-être qu'aujourd'hui sera la
journée sans araignée non et on espère
la seule de ce tournoi
les joueurs quand même après deux jours
d'intenses bataille
serait content de t'avoir un petit peu
soufflé tenir un peu moins tard et de
repartir de plus belle dès le lendemain
si c'est pour partir de plus de belles
le lendemain ah oui parce qu'il y aura
le loups en bracket avec voilà des
matchs couteau tirés pour se qualifier
pour revenir d'outre-tombe jusqu'à la
finale et affronter peut-être ce Magnus
Carson impérial jusque-là qu'il y aura
une journée de repos demain pour être
bien en forme mais est-ce que ça va pas
peut-être casser son rythme aussi tu
poses trop de questions la Fabien
laissons-le déjà se qualifier et ça
serait le même cas pour
toute façon
c'est à dire que tu délicieux jour de
repos mais
en tout cas on a encore envie encore une
partie extraordinaire tout en maîtrise
et maintenant une fois qu'on aura fait à
plomber on va carrément ouvrir la
colonne 1 pour la tour maintenant une
nouvelle cible ce pion à deux
c'est bon en tout cas les échecs à
Fabien surtout quand c'est joué à ce
niveau de précision
alors il a pris d'échanger il a décalé
sa tour en C8
qui nous rappelle un qui avait avant
c'est compétition le format dans 4
parties mais deux 7 gagnants sur 3 jours
et 3 jours ouais
c'est exactement c'est un format qui
qu'ils ont enlevé
je pense c'est une erreur parce qu'on
est le premier jour le premier set le
deuxième jour le deuxième 7 et le
troisième jour en cas d'égalité le
troisième set d'accord donc ce qu'ils
ont un peu remplacé par un armage et
Dron simple ouais mais bon c'est un peu
court peut-être
altora qui dort pas assez longtemps à
mon avis
enfin c'est parfois les obligations
aussi des formats on est obligé de les
de les faire de les raccourcir un
maximum comme ici pour plaire au public
ils ont fait le maximum pour quand même
ça évite
finalement que 6 heures de compétition
tous les jours
en tout cas ça défend pour le moment
fermer la defaut aussi mais qui peut
reculer soit en décès soit aller vers G4
attaquer le cavalier ou se planter en H3
tous les coups sont pas mal et ensuite
Magnus va avoir envie d'arriver avec une
tour en A3 vraisemblablement pour mettre
une pression latérale sur le plan C3
attaquer un petit peu le pion à dos
aussi et ramener une autre tour à 8
il va peut-être pas faire long feu
c'est la demi-finale GMP c'est la finale
winner bracket mais en quelque sorte la
demi-finale puisque tu devras rejouer
contre celui qui reviendra des loosers
ça donc il va couvrir la 7e rangée
défendre le pion vaisselle en cas
d'échange en 17 il reprend du cavaliers
bien sa structure cohérente tout est
bien défendu avant peut-être de passer à
l'attaque dans un deuxième temps des
faiblesses adverse
avec un plan qui pourrait être joli quoi
échange en 17 on reprend du cavalier on
met le pion B6 bien-sûr par le cavalier
et la torsades qui coulisse ensuite
très fin c'est toujours soyeux comme il
joue Magnus
il reste plus que 10
qui est pas très particulier
il va tout faire pour ne pas commencer
par une défaite qui compromettrait quand
même ses chances dans ce match même si
on a quand même déjà vu revenir dans le
tournoi il pourrait revenir des perdants
Fabien tout à fait il aurait qu'un match
à jouer demain d'ailleurs c'est un
adversaire déjà éprouvé après un long
match
vainqueur de saut contre les toilettes
saga un match qui promet quand même tu
tonnerre de dieu oh que oui faudra pas
le rater celui-là il vaut son pesant de
cacahuètes Fabien
on y pensait pas trop quand on a vu le
tableau début du tournoi mais ça a été
de genre vareux qui qui malgré leur
défaite des le premier tour sont revenus
et gagne les matchs les uns après les
autres et reviennent reviennent
reviennent ça me fait un petit peu
penser à Top Chef tout ça cette année
avec le candidat de la brigade cachée
en finale mais quand même tu vois
qui revient et gagne c'est un petit peu
ça le principe de ce stand en fait c'est
la brigade cachée
peut-être on pourrait la renommer comme
ça aussi
like you caché
ok il se met dans le rouge là
est-ce qu'elle compte pour le rapidorm
malheureusement non les parties sur
Internet ne sont pas homologués donc
elles ne comptent pas pour le classement
mais évidemment ça devrait à mon avis
même compter pour le classement
classique à mon avis oui
on va faire un classement qui compte
tout avec ce tournoi quand même avec un
coefficient supérieur pour pour ce
tournoi
peut-être déconnecté finalement parce
que les réfléchis un peu longtemps sur
un coup
à neutre
pour qui arrive en A4 et là maintenant
B6 le pion peut plus être attaqué
et puis les autres les uns après les
autres
ok il va arriver le 5 maintenant ça va
faire du grabuge
et finalement sur quelques
échange dans une structure un peu de
Gambi bengo et qu'on sait très favorable
pour les finales avec justement les
pièces qu'on adore regarder avec les
Noirs les deux tours et le foot casse
noir
arrête de taper efficacement sur les
lames avec une structure sans aucune
faiblesse et il a joué
les secondes ses graines maintenant pour
nous dire bec
qui a peut-être suivi la partie d'avant
qui a bien intégré le coach 6 très
important pour aider les maths du
couloir ruizi est-ce que
il veut te reprendre à droite on reprend
B6
plein de ressources
peut-être faire torcer ces trois il
s'accroche s'accroche mais bon
ça peut mal se passer
de connards
tu rentres dans le monde de Naruto
je ne connais pas bien Naruto
c'est quand même quelque chose qui doit
te manquer au quotidien non
vu que je me rends pas compte mais
probablement que oui c'est un grand
manquement à ta culture et ma culture
c'est-à-dire le Naruto le naruto
shippuden aussi
tu vois c'est une version c'est une
version un petit peu ouais un peu plus
loin et tu as le boruto aussi c'est le
fils de Naruto
assez exceptionnelles
comme tu le vois c'est le cavalier
revenu 5 le pion C4 va tomber comme
prévu
et c'est un château de cartes qui
s'effondre
parce que est en prise maintenant
village de la feuille cachée
ça va partir en C4
tellement de pions d'avance
le roi qu'il faut s'y monter
peut-être raté un C4 qui aurait facilité
la vie mais bon ça reste tellement
gagnant
du 3 secondes pour nous dire bec
il a combien il a que un pion plus pour
le moment va sûrement gagner le pion des
5 s'il a envie et puis il y a des
faiblesses partout et puis un troll puis
en G5 il a pu en passer c'est tellement
d'atouts
il va pouvoir couper toutes les cartes
adverses
en couper une première rangée 5
peut-être
monte le roi en tout cas
souvent me dire Beck qui défend bien
quand même souligner en très résistant
comme joueur
de ces énormes points forts
pour ça que Magnus est quand même assez
vigilant
pour ne pas laisser
le joueur ouzbek sans tirer mais il
s'est mis mal au temps Magnus finalement
pas aussi facile qu'il aurait dû l'être
donc il a fait un choix dans la position
donc c'est plus avoir si on passait mais
d'avoir repris des cartes comme ça ça
peut être permettre donc d'attaquer le
pion des cinq comme il le fait et aussi
éventuellement de
ça c'est bien joué
il y a plus d'espoir pour les blancs et
des pions passer lié de partout le roi
qui arrive en F5 voilà c'est fait
il abandonne derrière victoire de Magnus
Carlson dans cette première partie un
premier coup de butoir dans la tête de
son jeune adversaire ouzbek et on se
retrouve dans une petite dizaine de
minutes pour la suite à la suite du
tournoi à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est reparti Magnus qui arrive un
petit peu en retard pour la partie mais
qui vient d'envoyer le coup E4 et
[Musique]
nous n'avons pas de tempo on va voir
alors Fabien sicilienne
sicilienne suivi par cavalier 3e
manov que minus avait lui-même employé
contre Fabian lors du premier jour de ce
tournoi
qui surviendrait après le coup kevoli
mais il choisit un autre coup cavalier
s'attaque le Pione 4 il fait fout des
trois pour le défendre plutôt que
cavalier C3 ou classique
donc tous les trois défends le pion
n'est jamais à l'abri d'un retour de 0,2
à deux partout
non c'est vrai aussi
prendre une petite option mais prendre
une petite option effectivement
statistiques tu serais favorable
ok oui
alors qu'est-ce que tu en penses cette
position Fabien ok un érudit de la
théorie
non ben j'en pense que bon à Magnus a
choisi de jouer donc un étau de marozzi
exception E4 et C4 quand c'est
structures de sicilienne donc l'intérêt
de ses pions c'est de ralentir les
poussettes que ce soit des 5 ou B5 et il
va se placer tranquillement avec petit
rock avec peut-être B3 ou B2
et puis monter la dame et te ressentent
etc et
voilà alors après bon bah on va voir si
arrive à avoir une rupture avant ça et
quand il va mettre ses pièces en place
il peut choisir juste un système
hérisson donc avec un cavalier en
dessert après B6 elle d'avancer 7 etc
etc c'est très solide côté noir mais
c'est le genre de partie de manœuvre
normalement qui va bien qui a bien aller
à Magnus
bon je pense que les blancs peuvent
faire de même à moins à moins qui nous
envoie un petit gquattro
un peu
nouveau comme un air de jouer dans ses
hérissons mais finalement
on a déjà vu ça les blancs qui ne font
plus petit rock mais qui joue pour grand
rock même roi des deux non parfois et
voilà enfin ils partent par là-bas et
puis te pousse tout dans la gueule
bon vu la session dans le match moi je
sais pas j'irai pour petit rock et
je veux le truc ça il fait mais bon
Magnus
il sait très bien gérer la pression
qui est intense dans ce match et dans ce
tournoi donc
je partirai pas pour G4 à sa place ça me
paraît un peu trop on a bien un qui peut
jouer comme ça c'est peut-être bien lui
qui ne sera pas paralysé par l'enjeu
en tout cas il prend bien son temps
il prend bien son temps Magnus
et il a bien raison
il faut en prendre son temps
voilà disons ça peut influer la suite du
cours de la partie et évidemment du
match aussi comme tu le disais une
victoire quand même le mettre en bonne
position une nul ça le laisse plutôt pas
mal une défaite par contre ça relance
complètement un peu cette horreur donc
est-ce qu'il veut essayer de mettre un
coup de grâce quasiment dès maintenant
ou
finalement être plus dans la gestion
peut-être des questions qui se posent
lui-même avant de jouer son coup
une maestriette technique avec cette
attaque contre l'option C4 qui s'ensuit
décalé 5 mais qui ont entraîné de
nouveaux problèmes notamment le largeur
de la colonne et peut-être petit à petit
il est rentré il a gagné un pion puis un
second un bel échange de Tours pour
gagner une finale de fou quand même très
technique il fallait pousser des pions
et
donc maintenant voilà on va avoir ce qui
va nous donner dans l'étonnement de
Rocket plus on peut être en mode gestion
il gère
donc il fait baisser ce qui met en place
le plan peut-être donc avec le fond B7
et le cavalier ensuite en 17
schéma alors les blancs on pourrait
peut-être jouer avec A4 à 5 et tenter
d'aller donner un pion et comme ça sur
b.3 donc souvent faut attendre peut-être
que le casin soit plus en B8 pour pas
venir défendre en C6 mais dès que le
client en D7 ça peut être un plan
qui peut tout envoyer c'est intéressant
il joue pas juste F3 pour contenir un
éventuel full B7 il prend immédiatement
une belle diagonale une fois 5
Magnus qui joue donc de manière assez
assez ambitieuse
très ambitieuse même
c'est dur pour en directe
déjà sous pression comme dans la partie
précédente
oh que oui
bah attendre là que les coups arrivent
je faisais un petit coup de dames et 7
gardons toutes ces options et permettant
également cavalier B8 d'aller
éventuellement en D7 enquête qui est ici
sur la route
aussi jouer avec G4 ici un pour G5
mais il pourrait il pourrait parce
qu'évidemment c'est un plan sympa de
faire G4 G5 ça enlève le calibre 6 qui
est quand même une dernière pièce qui
défend le roi noir puis ensuite envoyer
la dame en H5 et ton F3 tu rage 3 ou la
poussée E5 ça va très très de concert
alors son G4 il faut toujours regarder
si un goût comme 5 pour réagir au centre
mais sûrement qu'il y avait
bloquer la 8 et après avoir alors il y a
fait tourcien qui reste un bon coup qui
se met dans le vis-à-vis de la dame
peut-être parfois on aura du cavalier
des cinq qui pourraient partir qui t'a
donné une pièce
qui domine très tôt et ça a l'air de
suivre pour l'instant le cours des
matchs des deux joueurs précédents avec
un Magnus très dominateur
avant la Coupe du monde
oh mais Magnus au moins il est il joue
pour les tournois majeurs cette année
c'est le grand Chester Croatie et ce
tournement
pour voilà c'est ça le moins important
après la Coupe du Monde il verra si le
reste des résidus de forme ou pas mais
en tout cas ici il se montre à l'apogée
de son art
ok oui
qui prend son temps mais là il le suivi
il a une position difficile
ça permet de tous les côtés le pion au 5
pour les blancs le cahier des 5
peut-être un moment peut-être j'ai 4g5
ça fait beaucoup de plans côté blanc
alors que les Noirs
pas facile de savoir où mettre les
pièces comment ça peut vraiment venir à
droite à gauche
ok oui une éclaboussure qui se prenne
en tout cas le tournoi extraordinaire on
le dira jamais assez
donc jouer malgré tout par on va dire
bec il y a pas de
penser qu'il y a des seins qui étaient
si dangereux
mais peut-être toujours ce G4 qui
pourrait partir
et c'est fait il envoie G4
ça fait mal
ça fait mal parce qu'il veut faire G5
prendre l'espace ça c'est le KFC
qui sont un petit peu asphyxi dans cette
position seulement sur trois rangées
sur ce rythme même si bon on aurait bien
aimé un match nul de 2 pour insister un
Armageddon mais forcément
trop au dessus de ses adversaires
ouais mais bon il y aura quand même le
looser bracket pour permettre de revenir
de l'arrière et peut-être le battre
finalement le coiffer au poteau
faut bien il conserve son fou sur cette
belle diagonale il va monter une attaque
ça va faire très très mal à partir
ça a l'air fort
bah il est dans le contrôle
défendre le pion au 4 puis j'ai 5 puis
coulisser
et partir de l'avant
quel démonstration
ce sera pas fini quand même à 0
ni ce match ni le tournoi bien
évidemment n'oubliez pas
c'est une sorte de finale aujourd'hui
mais c'est pas la grande finale du
tournoi non plus
après si tu reviens du loser bracket tu
dois gagner deux fois
oui mais en même temps ça permet d'avoir
quand même jauger la situation on aura
déjà eu un affrontement avec Magnus et
peut-être donc d'arriver un peu plus en
forme on aura pu étudier les forces et
les faiblesses de disséquer le jeu de
l'adversaire
non mais non là au moins un ressenti
arrière derrière l'ordinateur et
ces joueurs qui ne se jouent pas souvent
rencontrer rarement ses joueurs dans les
mêmes tournois
non plus peut-être ils sont rencontrés
que une dizaine une vingtaine de fois
jusqu'à présent
on se souvient un peu dans les
championnats du monde rapido Blitz
peut-être aussi à viscandi cette année
c'est dans d'autres tournois comme ceci
mais voilà ce qu'on a bien fait le tour
de son adversaire à ce qu'on a bien
jaugé
chaque partie on peut dire un
enseignement
et donc forcément quand il si jamais il
revient
du loser bracket de la brigade Hélène
Darroze là peut-être avec conseil de son
chef il pourra rivaliser
et bien mettre les épices qu'il faudrait
avec il prend beaucoup d'espace mais
voilà c'est toujours un peu le pendant
de prendre de l'espace c'est que les
pions peuvent être affaibli ensuite il
peut devenir des cibles voilà si un
moment les Noirs d'un coup comme D5 pour
essayer de se délivrer tout ouvrir ça
ouvrira leur dame vers le roi vous êtes
Le Fou B7 aussi et en même temps le 7
vers le pion beca 4 votre vigilant à
toutes ces coups de rupture qui peut
arriver en face
bien sûr
en tout cas ça réfléchit côté
H5 qui voilà tient des cases qui
bloquent voilà il bloque complètement
[Musique]
dans la position depuis ce tour c'est un
coup de butoirs
la taille du cahier tout en défendant
son fossette
ouais mais il a pas l'air si malin que
ça
si on prend le fou du coup
absolument passionnante Fabien
niveau de jeu impressionnant jusqu'à
maintenant
dans cette partie penser Magnus
proche de l'emporter
finalement peut-être un peu excès de
confiance
exceptions qui sont partis à droite à
gauche
et les fautes plus qu'une chose et que
la position s'ouvre aurait profité de ce
roi blanc un petit peu maintenant
délaissé qui a plus vraiment de
murailles devant lui
ok oui
alors ça a changé en E7 la dame qui se
décale par rapport à ce qui pourrait
être dangereux
ce que un coup comme F5 aurait pu partir
peut-être aussi côté noir puisque le
pion de 4 aurait été cloué en cas de
prise en passant les cavaliers aurait pu
reprendre ou les tours pour s'activer
ça aurait pu
mais ça n'a pas ça n'a pas été le cas
donc qui s'enlève mais c'est vrai qu'on
voit mal les blancs
[Musique]
attaqués maintenant vraiment une belle
réaction du genre ouzbek
très belle réaction
entre les deux joueurs et donc
ça réfléchit
plein d'options mais peut-être qu'un
coup simple comme tour C8
peut être jouable
même si il faut quand même rester
vigilant sur les blancs pour un moment
essayer de percer avec F5 ou quoi mais
ça peut leur être fatale d'ouvrir comme
ça ça délestera aussi la case de 5 donc
c'est une décision qu'il faut mûrement
réfléchir c'est pas évident
pas évident de savoir exactement quoi
faire peut-être un autre plan ça serait
de rapatrice qui est D4 en E2 vers G3
pour peut-être essayer de chasser ce
cahier H5 en cas de prise reprendre le
pion h et s'ouvrir la colonne pour une
tour qui pourrait coulisser derrière la
dame et en même temps laisser la case
des quatre vacances pour le fou qui
pourra regarder vers le roi alors c'est
un plan qui prend un peu de temps mais
peut-être
c'est serré en tout cas cette partie
moins clair que ce qu'on aurait pu
penser oui oui on s'attendait à ce que
Magnus puis s'écraser son adversaire et
au final final des esquives en face et
maintenant maintenant rien est clair
tout peut arriver c'est une sortie
vraiment à trois résultats vraiment ce
match qui tient finalement toutes ces
promesses ah le temps
2 minutes d'avance
on va voir
c'est quand même un petit peu aussi
dirigé quand c'est coup comme F5 ça
défend un peu le faux 3 en face de la
dame
j'imagine qu'il pourrait juste faire
reprendre
[Musique]
alors peut-être un accès sur aussi
le genre de position qui le favorise le
plus face à Magnus un peu plus
bordélique
on a vu ça dans la première partie que
Magnus quand c'était très technique qui
est impérial là peut-être tu peux
exister peu de bananes ici ou là un jeu
un peu plus un peu plus fou
je faisais vite alors peut-être pour la
rapatrie vers à 8 justement et faire une
grande pression donc cette le long de
cette longue diagonale qui a eu lieu en
tout cas jouer par Magnus pour peut-être
aller vers G3
s'il échange tu rêves de t'auras jamais
complètement je suis d'accord
G7 déjà il sera moins bien placé et puis
voilà complètement c'est peut-être des
damages 6 ou des quatre
des choses comme ça petit problème de
connexion aussi un chat
c'est quand même à noter
on a pas grand le cas de figure
et c'est bien dommage
c'est bien dommage
on attend le coup
qui n'arrive toujours pas
il joue au
alors 5 voilà c'est une réaction pour
que la position s'ouvre bloquer un peu
les blancs mais
[Musique]
qui était parti tout de suite et il fait
F6 ok alors là tout de suite ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué comme position
[Musique]
la pression là
trois fois deux
du C5 peut-être qui partira un moment
qui joue
bien joué
bien senti de la part du streamer
français
c'est mes positions ça fait avec les
Blancs
que je me sens le mieux
mais qui ne se sentirait pas bien
on est très heureux
résister aux attaques norvégiennes en
plus peut-être de ma coup de
remplacement comme tour D1 serait
possible
3 x 2 c'est pareil pas mal on peut faire
la même vie assez de B3 mais bon à trois
je me dis qu'on fait une pierre deux
coups donc
crème vis-à-vis un petit C5 qui pourrait
partir tôt ou tard
dans la position
question est-ce que tu commences par
tourner pour moi
je sais pas dure à dire peut-être à
trois c'est bien tourner un faut
regarder même si c'est ce qui se passe
mais du coup on joue plus avec A3 quoi
dans certaines
donc peut-être fou ces deux maintenant à
moins que ça faisait quand même de me
prendre ces quatre
prépare tout ça
il y a toute façon très bien aussi et
j'ai trois pourraient suivre par la
suite
tu aurais faite
est-ce que ça allait pas très bien
ensemble finalement
complexe de terminer
bon la position reste tendu c'est à dire
qu'on a une bonne tête pour les blancs
mais
une erreur est vite arrivée et on a rien
en plus donc il peut se passer plein de
choses il vient de choisir de prendre un
MP6 et on sent que ça peut s'ouvrir que
les deux rois peuvent être en danger
ça peut aller dans les deux sens tout ça
donc tu vas faire cette tour Eiffel
va-t-il partir va-t-il ramener le cahier
en G7
ça commence à être peu
ouais
on le sait plein de ressources on le
sait plein de ressources et capable
peut-être de sortir un tour du chapeau
un tour de magie on espère en tout cas
pour le suspense dans ce match dans
cette compétition quoique je parle de
suspense mais c'est vrai qu'il a une
deuxième vie Fabien oui quoi qu'il en
soit le genre perd dans ce match ne
pourras pas trop déçu alors il nous sort
un G5 inattendu
pas piqué des hannetons personnellement
je ne l'ai pas vu venir ce coup
parce que
toi tu en l'air
ça m'aurait pas trop traverser l'esprit
mais c'est là quand même qu'on va la
différence entre un génie quand même de
cette
commentateur comme moi
[Rires]
j'ai 5 peut-être un très joli coup
j'aurais même pas envisager
[Musique]
je crois toujours pas en fait
en fait mais bon
normal il prend le matériel donc
maintenant attention quand même à torche
G8 il fera une enfilade
donc il peut enlever le roi il peut
enlever la dame il fait mettre un
cavalier au milieu à voir mais sur le
coup logique qui serait d'un HK puis
tours J4 mais il va faire sauter le pion
au 4
et donc cette offre compte se réactiver
tout d'un coup elle peut être dame un
petit peu coulisser vers G7 également et
où venir en C6 faire une batterie avec
le fou c'est
G4 qui arrive c'est pas facile à jouer
il a décidé que c'était le moment toute
le bordel avec les noirs et de tenter de
contre-attaquer
il donne tout
il y a peut-être partir pour dommage
sister G8 kg G3
et prends G3 pions prend bouffe le 4
après peut-être F6
mais bon quand il bouffe les trois F7
qui est obligé de faire reprendre
il a fait j'ai trois directs ça marche
aussi ça peut être une inversion de coup
seulement
quand j'évite peut-être dommage 6 donc
ça revient dans le truc qui traîne
d'abord
il vient se placer un peu tout tenir
peut-être ton F3 mais à voir bon pour
l'instant elle est très bien pour les
blancs mais les pions peuvent tomber un
peu comme des mouches hein si eux quatre
tombent que les fous sont échanges il y
a le pion c'est 4 ans là j'ai trop un
peu plus en l'air il peut y avoir un
deux qui saute à voir
il faut deux ce qu'on va demander Bill
ets 4 en fait
essayer de forcer qui est champion
prendre moi je me donne la case H2 pour
le roi et je
sais pas faute peut-être qu'elle est F4
dessus
et je prends le cadre à ce moment-là
puis on prend et de prendre ensuite
ensuite aux quatre avec le cavalier
peut-être
de toute façon
après la tu es contente on aura une
minute de plus hein
de prendre sa stabilise a priori
mais oui on reprend puis on prend dame
il y a que un pion d'avance mais ça
reste mieux pour les blancs et
normalement on aura un petit peu quand
même laissé passer l'orage
peut-être l'autre option c'est juste
froid cela dit
enlève ce four en prise des fantômes
Magnus qui prend donc on prend dame
prank et il prend 4 j'imagine
et sur fouet trois fois
pour tenir C4 parce qu'en fait prise oh
ok prends OK
enfin de partir rocabulesque
ils ont besoin de bol là
s'il veut pas tout calculer l'intuition
qui va venir dans un position un peu
compliqué et pas simple à gérer et si je
vais pas
intermédiaire
de donner ce pion moi j'ai pensé au coup
mais tu reprends des 6 peut-être dame
prend des 6 je sais pas tu t'es quand
même ouvert
fort c'est le premier coup qui m'est
venu à l'esprit en fait mais je me suis
dit
pourquoi faire
maintenant lève le cavalier mais bon tu
t'ouvres tellement le roi j'ai
l'impression qu'il va la perdre en plus
qui peut arriver côté noir maintenant
puisque toujours sur cavalier prend il y
a le même histoire de dangereux
mais oui ça pourrait du coup il se barre
avec le roi mais la tour elle va venir
en 8 directement
mais ça va encore parce que il y a
égalité matérielle et trois noirs il est
bien mais
mieux avoir mais à voir quand même ça
peut vite tourner oula ça s'appelle un
punto non
bon
moment où ça devait être allé sa
position pour tourner 8 propose des
échanges madame très bien passée le roi
en sécurité
c'est la même position avec deux pions
moins quoi voilà c'était la même chose
il y a deux coups il va risque de
peut-être tomber même il enchaîne les
coûts un peu rapidement
il survit alors attention encore des
échecs peut-être qu'il y a F5 on aura
des quatre quand même attention
[Musique]
et ce roi faible finalement
qui va se prendre des échecs et des
raisons de maths
en bolesque alors on était animé pendant
pendant un court moment on a une
dernière minute de folie
mais Magnus qui prend donc le large et
qui pourraient s'imposer de la troisième
partie imagine cette journée décevante
pas d'armaillerdon et pas de 4 parties
catastrophique peut-être qui nous attend
on espère cap d'où ça adoraf sauve la
miss Fabien dans la dernière partie elle
nous offre au moins au moins une
quatrième partie merci à tous d'avoir
suivi on se retrouve dans une petite
dizaine de minutes
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyses avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur l'échiquier vous
pouvez choisir parmi une multitude de
notation de coûts d'animation
d'émoticônes et même vos personnalités
préférées du monde des échecs des
émoticônes et les emojis disparaîtront
au bout de quelques secondes en revanche
les notations de coûts et les animations
spéciales restent sur l'échiquier
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit effacées pour ce
faire il suffit de cliquer avec le
bouton gauche de la souris sur l'emoji
ou de cliquer sur le bouton Tout effacer
tous et amusez-vous bien sur Chess.com
et c'est reparti alors dans cette
troisième partie du match on rappelle
que Magnus Carlson mène deux points à 0
après deux victoires
dans les deux premières rondes dans
cette troisième partie nous dire becator
avec les pièces blanches et dans
l'obligation de gagner s'il ne gagne pas
il perdra ce match et se retrouvera dans
le loser bracket où il retrouvera le
vainqueur du match entre
un petit peu la surprise de ce tournoi
mais en même temps il a perdu qu'un
match c'était contrebienne au carwana et
encore il l'a perdu parce que il ne
savait pas comment enlever l'auto Quinn
il aurait fait une promotion cavalier
qui sait ce qui serait passé dans ce
match toujours est-il qu'il est
maintenant opposé demain à Wesley sceaux
et on verra ce qui se passe d'ici là en
tout cas maintenant avec les pièces
blanches va tout donner pour essayer de
remporter cette partie et essayer de
revenir dans ce match donc l'ouverture
est une un grand big dame on peut
repasser les coups si vous voulez des
quatre des tu as fait des cinq mais si 4
6 KF3 D5 G3 C5 donc le coup c'est 5
contre la Catalane de abusa Toro V à
noter que Magnus est quand même un grand
spéciste de la Catalane il est employé à
de nombreuses reprises et notamment lors
de son match contre Yann n'est pas bien
chier lors du Championnat du Monde
2021 il me semble ou 22 peut-être
c'est pour ça que j'arrive un peu en
retard parce qu'il y avait les stats de
chasse ah alors il y a plus de
précisions pour pour Abdou ça t'auras
globalement sur ces parties mais
pas sur ces deux parties mais en
généralise mieux les avantages donc il
est il est censé être devant quand même
Nadir Beck on va voir si ça se vérifie
pas trop mais peut-être que dans une
telle opposition il n'arrive pas à
mettre en place son jeu positionnel elle
a peut-être besoin elle a peut-être
besoin de plus de temps d'ailleurs c'est
plus précis dans les ouvertures aussi
on va voir ce que ça ce que ça donne
peut-être qu'il arrive pas à jouer à son
max max contre Magnus qui dépend en
pleine possession de ses moyens par
contre les autres peut-être qu'il est
plus en possession et qu'il arrive donc
à mieux déployer tout ce qui sait faire
c'est une possibilité en tout cas avec
les pièces blanches dans l'obligation de
gagner un tu l'as rappelé Fabien tout à
fait c'est quand même l'enjeu de cette
partie et Magnus souvent qui étouffe ses
adversaires et qui qui parfois
impressionnent
et puis confronté au monstre tout d'un
coup enfin une chute un peu
parce que quand même t'affrontes
peut-être le plus grand joueur de
l'histoire ou en tout cas l'un des trois
meilleurs et donc peut-être tu es un
petit peu impressionné
statistique et l'intelligence
artificielle ne peut pas mentir Fabien
alors est-ce que c'est sur ce tournoi ou
les parties internet je pense qu'ils ont
joué depuis le début de la saison
très très impressionnant ce tableau
important
petite information importante
et donc
en tout cas donc
pour un petit peu couper ce fou G2
et essayer de terminer le développement
si possible à une dame avec ses 6 si on
peut peut-être fouder 7 ou 6 aussi pour
aller en face du four on verra
écoutez blanc un dossoft qui fait fouder
2 donc sûrement mettre le caillou en C3
et qu'en cas de prise il n'est pas
reprendre un pion mais bien du Fou
regardez une structure beaucoup plus
solide et souple
c'est souple
c'est souple Fabien
je vois bien une victoire de la douce à
Torah dans cette partie Fabien
relancerait un peu le match
et peut-être alors c'est là il pourrait
enchaîner dans la suivante si on reprend
confiance il retrouve sa précision
légendaire à ce moment-là qui sait ce
qui pourrait se passer puis une
troisième avec l'armée ce ne serait pas
grave puisqu'il y a une deuxième vie on
le rappelle Fabien il y a le louper
bracket vous perdez vous avez une
deuxième vie dans le tournoi donc ce
n'est pas décisif je le rappelais donc
oui le perdant de ce match qui
retrouvera le vainqueur du match qu'on
suivra bien sûr demain avec grand
attention à 17h entre Weasley Sow et
saga
match palpitant entre les deux oui mais
je pense peut-être que favori comme je
le rappelais finalement il a perdu un
match de Carona mais seulement parce
qu'il savait pas enlever l'autocuisne
oui imagine
là bon peut-être qu'il serait là ici en
discuter ce match donc
raison Fabien depuis Kelly les vannes et
puis je sais plus il a aimé quelqu'un
d'autre je passe tellement de choses
beaucoup de choses dans le tournoi donc
on oublie un peu toutes les péripéties
marquante Fabien on ne peut pas de
partie qui rentreront dans dans
l'histoire
qu'on peut parfois avoir du mal à se
rappeler
de tous ces chefs-d'oeuvre qui sont
joués dans un des points culminant de la
saison d'ailleurs peut-être allez un
petit reproche mais bon je me permets je
me permets bon
non c'est un peu dommage parce que
finalement on n'a pas pu suivre tous les
matchs tu vois on a dû faire des choix
et en dessous
etc et
on n'a pas pu voir ce qui se passait
chez Wesley exactement chaque match un
peu les uns après les autres
pourquoi pas carrément en décalé
pourquoi pas un peu après juste tu fais
match numéro match numéro 2 matchs voilà
enfin tu et là on aurait pu tout voir
donc voilà on a vraiment une grande
journée avec peut-être
au moins 16 parties peut-être 20 là bon
on en a eu pour notre argent j'ai envie
de dire
c'est pas faux c'est vrai qu'on reste un
petit peu sur notre fin avec comme tu
disais voilà des parties du tourisme
saga par exemple qu'on a raté exactement
donc on a les résultats mais on a on n'a
pas forcément pu voir les parties on a
dû faire des choix je crois qu'ils se
sont pas forcément toujours avérés être
les bons voilà après c'est subjectif on
se dit bon Magnus quand même intéressant
et on a gagné très content de ce qu'on a
vu et du niveau de jeu déployé mais
voilà d'autres gens peut-être aussi
mérité l'antenne et la primeur on était
obligé de faire des choix comme tu le
dis alors que si ça a joué tout en
décalé on pourrait on pourrait tout voir
et finalement
comme tu le dis on en aurait pour notre
temps pour notre argent et je pense que
ça ferait aussi plaisir au public qui
reste un petit peu sur sa fin lui aussi
finalement les journées sont courtes
aujourd'hui ça commence à 17h il n'est
que 20h30 et en cas de match nul la
journée n'aurait durer que 4 heures
qui finalement n'est rien
non c'est pas
mais
le spectacle est au rendez-vous
Fabien peut-être Dame des histoires des
8 petite pression petite pression avec
cette paire de fou le fouger 2 qui d'un
coup
peut-être la possibilité d'aller prendre
un pion alors bon peut-être un bref coup
prend ces 6 puis on prend tout reprendre
les noirs
en train de faire le travail
qui est bien placé qui peut revenir
peut-être vers A4 un jour et qui bloque
un peu de câble à 3
alors peut-être ça prend pour aller
chercher une petite pizza
on est raté finalement lundi qui doit
trouver un aujourd'hui comme tu le vois
finalement partie qui me dure peut-être
pas assez et qui te laisse le temps de
perdre ton régime exactement mais j'ai
le droit au repas bonus par semaine qui
pourrait peut-être être une compensation
du par rapport au manque de spectacle
aujourd'hui je reste sur moi
effectivement
sur un gym strict c'est les consignes
mais j'ai le droit une fois par semaine
et donc comme aujourd'hui bon on a pas
trop parler alors j'espère que demain
par contre alors demain je
vais peut-être te mettre le coup de
grâce là ce sera que deux bo2 puisque
j'y suis préparé mais j'espère quand
même que au moins un match il y aura un
partout
comme ça un pion et sur B3 il faut
prendre B3 le pion des deux restes en
prises
joli Magnus qui récupère le pion qui l'a
entre guillemets sacrifié mais B3 qui
serait donc le coup classique pour
enfermer ses fous dans le coin un peu
comme parce qu'il a fait contre Fisher
de l'autre côté
il faut prendre les trois qui devient la
dame qui défendrait plus le fou des deux
après tous les perdants pour un point de
bonus et continuer à faire des brackets
sous looser bracket qui continuera jouer
à en décaler pour peut-être des points
de bonus dans la saison complète
au final
[Musique]
bonus doivent se mériter
c'est une très très bonne idée
super looser bracket ouais comme dit
body boy qui manque un petit peu
les dames sont échangées une course mais
en face en 8 un Magnus qui a bien sûr
tout intérêt liquide et ton petit peu
nul ça
avec les pions mais
je vais me faire un cavalier C4
plus on voit plus les cavaliers mais sur
les fous de le reposer rajoute des
chances de nuls quand on rentre en
finale
pour l'instant qui maîtrise
mais il est il est facile depuis le
début du tournoi
il a gagné combien de champions mais ce
qui serait pas en train de
rattraper finalement tu en sport
parallèle Djokovic et ses grands thèmes
c'est possible en train de jouer pour
les livres d'histoire Magnus
malheureusement j'ai pas fait le
décompte il faudrait peut-être pour
demain je le plongerai dans les archives
et essayer de compter tout ça mais oui
je crois qu'il avait remporté les deux
premières éditions
peut-être la première en tout cas il
veut contre le carreaux la finale l'acte
finale Armageddon déjà peut-être en
train de s'approcher à grands pas du
Rota du record de Novak d'ailleurs un
peu comme le tennis ce tournage change
parfois de format le tennis qui
maintenant s'uniformise avec le super
tie break assez 6 mais avant certains
faisaient un tie-break genre comme le US
Open
d'autres laissaient jouer une vitam
eternables etc et donc oui c'est
champion de chez soi qui ont changé de
format au début donc c'était des sept en
quatre parties
qui répond donc à toutes nos attentes à
qui permet de pas avoir un joueur qui se
fait éliminer tôt dans le tournoi
voilà on le voit au moins deux jours
alors que là il est là il peut revenir
et peut-être même remporter le tournoi
spécialiste de cette tournoi au tout
début
[Musique]
Carlson d'ailleurs
c'est un peu un mano à Manon entre les
deux avant peut-être un peu de baisser
pavillon
peut-être moins flamboyant par la suite
alors Magnus qui a changé ce fou donc il
y a plus de foot le reposer mais il va
jouer donc le fou contre le cavalier
peut-être partir aussi avec le fou pas
laisser la tour adverse rentrer en
dessin et envoyer le pion
rôle de bloqueur mais on rappelle que le
but top n'est pas seulement d'essayer de
faire nul encore une très très belle
partie et bien de gagner c'est encore
une très très belle partie
tout en maîtrise
alors
ou à 4 ou 3 vêtements
qui peut être défendu relativement
facilement quand même avec ton C8
sont des parties très intéressantes
c'est ma Sween n'a encore une fois
un spectacle quand même ils ont du mal
gagner ils doivent vraiment ouais mais
tu vois
quand même très intéressantes et
beaucoup d'abnégation chez les joueurs
quand même magnifique journée une
nouvelle fois
et donc il va essayer de trouver
faire jaillir l'eau de la pierre dans
cette position
je suis facile souvent que de faire
jaillir le la pierre de l'eau plus
difficile
ça fait un peu des ricochets
on en redemande
mais dès demain jusqu'à vendredi et puis
il y aura un autre tournoi donc fin août
il me semble un autre en septembre
[Musique]
dû être après la Coupe du monde qui
aurait pu servir d'échauffement mais
finalement ça coûte de servira
d'échauffement au prochain
donc finalement ça a du sens ce
calendrier l'un dans l'autre
et donc voilà un prochain tour à fin
août un autre fin septembre et alors là
le Clos du spectacle en
décembre en décembre avec le la grande
finale peut-être des califes avant
d'ailleurs des choses je sais pas
surtout décembre ça va être magnifique
ça a peut-être remplacer les speeches
d'ailleurs
ment
que 3h30 donc forcément pas au niveau
quoi
je sais pas trop pourquoi il a pas de
tenté
[Musique]
il veut sûrement aller vers vers des
quatre mais bon ça va quand même libérer
un petit peu ce pion
[Musique]
quel jour on est quel jour
qui ramène son enjeu qui veut l'enlever
la tour donc qui anticipe
avec un coup de tour des 7 coupons le
roi adverse et il a peut-être envie
d'aller en à 7 ce plastique
chaque pièce défendrait son pion
mais c'est peut-être un petit peu passif
quand même tout ça
pourra laisser quelque part un petit peu
le champ libre blanc pour
[Musique]
on l'espère pour faire deux trois trucs
et pourquoi pas aller chercher chercher
un point entier dans cette partie on
l'espère Fabien
vous offrir une super 4e partie de tous
les dangers pour minus
qui me permettrait de vivre
une petite trois quart d'heure de plus
aujourd'hui d'échecs peut-être sauver le
régime et oui tu resterais sur ta faim
et chicanement parlant
c'est vrai que c'est un des énormes
problèmes de tous ces temps d'échec
c'est que ça joue pas pas longtemps
finalement
j'en ai sont souvent trop courtes que ce
soit ici ou
dans d'autres tournois c'est un peu le
reproche finalement qu'on a eu sur le
champion du monde le match entre Ding
Liège et Napoli
[Musique]
il se battait trop vite
je crois qu'il va la perdre réellement
c'est très beau
à droite à gauche
spectacle est au rendez-vous une
nouvelle fois peut-être pas la bonne
décision de Magnus or pris ce foot 15
novembre avec son cavalier pour rentrer
dans cette finale là qui pensait
peut-être tenir facilement en
tenant tous ses pions mais voilà on a
dit un petit peu passif peut-être une
position et tout d'un coup les blancs
qui sont arrivés à créer de l'harmonie
dans leur pièce une torsadée on sait
toujours très fort
et ce cavalier qui va être à l'abander
revenu vers le centre et qui commence à
créer peut-être des menaces un petit peu
qu'on l'option C5
Maxime qui se délecte ah il est très
heureux
on y serait bien que les parties dure
plusieurs jours
c'était plus longues les matchs
pourraient durer plusieurs jours
à l'ancienne un peu avec les parties
ajournées mais là peut-être même pas
journée juste on joue on joue on joue
quoi la condition physique entre en
ligne de compte
parce que réfléchit qui se rend compte
maintenant que finalement les choses pas
si facile et qu'il y a une position
délicate à défendre
il se prépare peut-être déjà mentalement
à revenir pour une quatrième partie et
peut-être pas ultime
que fait preuve de beaucoup de
résilience dans ce match
et s'il venait à gagner une partie
peut-être alors comme le conseil de
Murtas gagner une partie puis une autre
et qui sait
avec nous ce qui envoie le pion h
peut-être essayer d'échanger des pions
réduire le nombre de pions sur
l'échiquier pour donner plus de chance
de nulle par la suite mais ce sera une
défense délicate quoi qu'il en soit
peut-être qu'il y aille B2 maintenant on
va chercher le pion à 4
il va se faire défoncer
H5 qui est parti
il va la perdre il va la perdre
malheureusement
c'est quand même pour notre plus grand
bonheur
malheureusement pour lui oui mais
heureusement pour nous
quatrième partie
délecte-toi et peut-être et peut-être
que j'en demande beaucoup mais on peut
se mettre à rêver
là on peut
alors peut-être
on n'est pas loin d'une journée de rêve
finalement
pas ça à côté de sa finale hein
plus délicat
mais bon comme tu l'avais dit de se taf
très très très précis et peut-être qu'il
a retrouvé de la super de sa superbe
pour cette partie c'est vrai que lors
des prochains ce qu'on a pas trop su
c'est la Division 3
un petit peu
on aurait pu se délecter
de quelques matchs
de 3e division
c'est vrai c'est vrai peut-être cramique
et dans ce tournoi notre représentant
tricolore
et puis d'autres joueurs je sais plus
qui peut-être je vous dirafe
on aurait pu se délecter
dans les pions vont tomber notamment
peut-être le pion c'est 5 mais est-ce
une bonne idée de prendre ce fiancé 5
rien n'est moins sûr c'est un pion ça se
mange Fabien et peut-être il pourrait
aller prendre le pion à 4 plutôt parce
que je me demande sur sur caille pro C5
s'il peut pas y avoir peut-être le roi
qui se rapproche
pour se délecter exactement on sait
qu'il adore le jeu
et finalement ça donne un petit
challenge d'une quatrième partie
voir d'une cinquième finalement
ils ont scénario j'ai l'impression que
c'était peut-être plus favorable de
gagner quitte en gagner un des deux le
pion a que le pion C qui donnera
peut-être des contre-champs au nord le
long de la colonne C justement pour
attaquer le pion C3 essayer de faire
disparaître cette dame attention il veut
mettre la tour en des deux et le et le
fou on C4
il part là dessus
on dit que Laurent est en finale
peut-être de Division 3
on ne sait pas
si on croit qu'on rate un petit peu on
passe on passe à côté d'une partie du
spectacle
j'ai pas envie de dire de par ton
initiative mais presque
vous pourrez commencer les live un petit
peu plus tôt si la division 3 se joue en
décalé Fabien c'est possible je crois
que peut-être on pourrait peut-être
un cap back pour Abdou à être kingso
pas fait encore Magnus qui défend pour
le moment c'est 4
sûrement
quoi d'autre
chose un autre coup il y a eu quatre
à ce moment là je sais pas ce que ça
change
pour lui pourquoi il a fait
peut-être même pas prendre
on va avoir le droit à la quatrième
partie les amis c'est génial
ouais c'est sûr roi des quatre j'ai
juste donné un pion de plus
c'est assez magique Fabien ce qu'on est
en train de vivre
avoir le droit à une quatrième partie et
peut-être même pas ultime
gros suspense du coup
je pense qu'il pourrait avoir un enjeu
4 3
défense latérale et les pions commencent
à avancer
peut-être tourner depuis monter le roi
etc
devrait gagner sans trop de soucis
c'est bien avec Maggie fasse bien durer
cette partie
ça a pas l'air super dur à gagner mais
bon
après hein
de quelque chose comme ça peut-être le
temps de sa chance aussi sur ce facteur
là du jeu
le pion c'est maintenant qui avant ce
qui tente d'attaquer le pion F3
c'est choper H2
et qui sait peut-être il se met trop mal
au temps
bientôt passer sous la minute
on voit son chrono passer en rouge mais
pas pendant longtemps il a ramené le roi
E3 pour défendre l'option C4 c'est une
répétition gagner un peu de temps
pendant un moment
autour des 5 attaque G5
peut-être alors il ferait ses 5 à ce
moment-là pour tout solidifier de la
sorte
ça a l'air pas mal quand même
l'air pas mal du tout Fabien
en train de se délecter
une finale de roi
gagnant
pour se rapprocher
donner le droit
alors ton Citroën D2
peut-être même plus fort que tu auras
des cadres ça prend les cases de retour
de la tour que ce soit c'est de ou c'est
[Musique]
G4
pour commencer
les gens qui se délègue dans le chat
avec une délectante
alors est-ce que
il peut rater le ratable
on sera déception quand même
mais bon
il défend plus qu'il ne devrait
aller une déco
panique
10 secondes
avec trois pions contre donc qui
pourrait sortir contre zéro qui doit qui
doit être gagnante mais bon il n'a pas
montré une technique impériale jusqu'à
lors
il place bien sa tour quand même
derrière l'avion passé qui veut envoyer
ta technique est pas terrible pour le
moment
6 suppose
ou un nouveau tour Eiffel
c'est plus facile
simplement mais
c'est quand même intéressant de le voir
des fentes comme ça ça peut être
instructif
si on se retrouve en difficulté de la
sorte des fois de savoir plus ou moins
qu'elle peut être le setup le plus
résistant plus difficile à casser par
l'adversaire
il revient quand même il défend de
manière réontée
on dit dans le chat oui il est prédit ça
t'aura fêté plus fort mais là si la roi
G5 c'est nul bon encore
et compagnie mais ok
on se délecte pas là
incroyable
c'est fou d'avoir raté ça il a vraiment
raté des trucs faciles
il doit pas être en train de se délecter
là
et c'est nul
incroyablement que trois parties et
Magnus donc qui s'impose
dans ce match et qui se qualifie donc
directement par la grande finale de
vendredi qui demain un jour de repos qui
va pouvoir se délecter en jouant il lui
reste plus qu'un match à gagner Fabien
pour remporter le magnifique
exactement vraiment beau on a
l'impression encore une fois on parle de
tous les petites détails le cerveau dans
la coupe
derrière l'argent
à gauche à droite
un dégradé aussi dans le ciel couleur
pastel qui part un petit peu du violet
pour aller finalement jusqu'au turquoise
exactement non magnifique magnifique
pour un artiste Doval
pour nous
faire un trophée de la sorte
sera gagné par forcément le plus
méritant puisqu'il y a cette défaite
mais donc on le rappelle l'information
quand même importante à toi perdu mais
il est pas éliminé il reviendra demain
pour jouer contre le vainqueur du match
West les sceaux utorizaya qui remonte du
loser bracket jour on leur match entre
eux puis affront à tous à tort pour
peut-être peut-être aller chercher
vendredi un 14 juillet Fabien
une victoire de renom
exactement donc on peut se donner des
rendez-vous donc demain à 17h pour le
sous-titrer de saga
qui rejoindra Magnus avec une seule vie
pas de attention alors voilà vendredi
ça promet ça promet tout ça on a vu
comme staff comme étais pas loin et
pouvait mettre un mâle le jus en
norvégien on verra s'il peut faire
vaciller ouais c'est sautsaga demain
Fabien je suis impatient de retrouver
c'est c'est parti demain donc
rendez-vous 17h désolé ça finit un petit
peu tôt aujourd'hui que 4h10 de
compétition mais on espère revenir plus
fort demain merci à tous ciao ciao